[Music]
two
what is up people
june 27th
it's monday
[Music]
it's h3tv welcome everybody
yes yes yes here we are
a quick thank you to our a wonderful
sponsor hellofresh
hellofresh delivers fresh quality
produce from the farm to your door in
less than a week so you can savor summer
flavors all season long get 16 free
meals plus three free gifts
with a code h3 tv 16 at hellofresh.com
h3tv16
do you show any of those
scrumptious meals
i didn't but i can uh
got them right here
yeah just show one there you go see look
at that flatbread damn
all
right thank you
also uh yeah
what's going on back there
uh we're just having some issues with
the visuals
uh dan and ian are sorting them out as
we speak
okay i was frozen
my screen was
alrighty well
welcome guys
coming off my birthday
i'm
weekend
you get lit
i drink and let's go it just ruins me
dude
[Music]
i didn't even drink that much but i
drank two days in a row which is like
insane whoa dude party animal
and i'm just tired i'm exhausted
um
uh but i will say that uh it was fun
how was everyone's weekend
good it was good
fun
sam is turning the frick up with that
new hair color
blowing up
everybody is losing their mind over
sam's new hair
it color ladies looks amazing
my goodness
thank you thank you
yeah dude people were freak i saw it on
the subreddit first
i think i'm used to it it's so weird
it actually looks really like it really
suits you it's kind of interesting it
looks so good what is it is it like red
or is it auburn what what are we doing i
think it's like copper i don't know
copper yeah i guess copper
interesting i'm trying to find a photo
of you that's like 3 000 likes dude
there it is yes dude
3 000 likes on the subreddit
oh damn
there it is
who's sam
someone said post root canal red
she had a root canal on friday oh [ __ ]
how would the root canal go
it was actually i showed up and the
dentist was like i don't think you need
a root canal
so he ended up he was able i cracked my
tooth on a tic tac i like bit down on a
tic tac and oh my god use of my tooth
like came off but he was able to fix it
without doing the root canal so did a
different doctor tell you needed a root
canal or no it was the same doctor but
after he was like in there
he was like oh i don't think you need a
root canal so actually worked out oh way
better god dude but yeah
if he was a quack-ass freak he could
have just given it to you to charge you
more
no he was real he was great i loved him
shout out
um
you know i saw a lot of super troopers
too up there a lot of nice people saying
hi
there's one girl that i saw on the way
out amy that she has a photo with you oh
yeah from like a month ago
it's just such a crazy coincidence let
me find this one all right i have it
right here
yeah so this girl
very nice by the way we we found her
when we were leaving
super nice and she said she just ran
into uab
and so if i go to her profile
let's see submitted
then the look at this there's a photo
with a b
from five months ago what are the
chances of that there's no such thing as
the i love her actually you know why
because i was with lena's whole family
and then she came up to me made me look
like a big celebrity oh yeah that felt
good yeah
go tell everyone back home that's
awesome don't forget it yes
what are the chances though huh
oh
so shout out to the super troopers out
there love y'all
that was nice
that's one nice thing about going out
is that you know there's lots of lovely
people out there that tell me nice
things that make me feel good
otherwise i'd have no reason to leave
the house ever right
it's still not enough frankly i have to
be forced
uh we got a lot to get to today my mom
is calling in
we have a big game plan my mom
challenged
me
to a monarch butterfly knowledge contest
we have selected from our audience
a donark mega fan who's going to be
participating around two o'clock
and their fate rides on my mom every
question she gets right the caller gets
25 bucks
wow how you guys feeling how the
questions come out pretty good pretty
good um you know because your mom
kind of initiated this whole thing she
just randomly messaged ethan and i like
a week ago i was just like what if you
guys quizzed me on a bunch of monarch
butterfly [ __ ] yeah and we were like
okay sure why not well and i said mom i
said mom you're stepping to me so we're
not gonna make them easy right
and i'm looking at these these are not
easy yeah baby no i don't think she's
gonna get all these science facts i
don't know maybe she will she spends a
lot of time talking and thinking about
monarch butterflies so you know what
maybe she'll blow us all away yeah
well either way i'm actually looking
forward to
checking in with my mom
and uh
actually a lot of stuff came up now i
want to ask you guys straight at the top
of the show here
there was a discussion in here right
before
the show started
the black eyed peas you may know their
song called um let's get it started
let's get it started in here but did you
know before it switched to let's get it
started
it was called and said let's get
[ __ ]
now
this must have [ __ ] with a lot of
people's heads this is crazy mandela
[ __ ] yeah there were multiple people in
this office that were completely unaware
of this yeah olivia thought i was just
making a shitty joke i'm like no that
was the name of the song sam and i both
grew up i guess we were too young to
know the dirty version but we just were
introduced ableist version
dirty the ableism yeah
well i it unlocked the memory of me
because i forgot about this too but just
listen to this okay this is how it
starts
[Music]
that's a hell of a way to start a song
the concept of this song is so crazy
and you know the course is let's get
[ __ ] in here so what well you know
my question to you guys is go ahead with
the drop please
yeah
so is that a sound bite that we can use
or is that too offensive is basically my
question to you all
because i i'm under the assumption that
i think it's fine just because of the
context of it
but if context has not saved me in the
past and it won't i mean at all the
whole thing with the sound it will be
used out of context you know what could
be funny in a way that will be offensive
because zach is in the controls and he's
joker brain
the clean version drop
letting all of us know who are in on the
joke see that's like that with you
funnier because it's through two
different like veils of comedy you know
right
i don't think it's funnier i don't know
if it's funnier it's more appropriate i
have both
well let's let's do a poll well hold on
now let's do a poll before we jump to
conclusions i gotta say i think we're
gonna get an r word pass on this one
i gotta say i uh oh somebody already did
the poll um
uh
see uh that's
was that sound bite that was me that was
me sorry oh i open when i open the
stream so i can read chat it plays the
song
like yeah the most random
oh [ __ ] wow it's closer than i thought
it would be yeah
uh i was looking at the chat when we
started talking about this
and kind of confirming this theory that
there's a generational divide on this
it's pretty evenly divided of people
saying what like as if they had never
heard of this and other people saying
yeah of course everybody knows that so
well pull up the results because you
guys can see that it's actually quite a
bit closer i think it's than i thought
it would be it's like 55 45
tardis so i think that's probably going
to be a pass
as someone said 50 bucks thank you
kaylee said as a special educator and a
family member of someone who is severely
disabled please do not sound bite this
so there you have it okay i'm glad we
asked
let's get it just the first note
it's so funny let's get it started
i think if we the thing is it's going to
lose its meaning we can't do a whole
like meme from this one little moment
like our [ __ ] is inside enough as it is
well what if we just play it sparingly
like it's got to be the right moment
like shut up [ __ ] yeah just like comes
listen you're the guy i i believe it to
you zach but you gotta you gotta live
with the consequences of of playing it
that's that's very fine
i've i know from people are saying
people are saying my daughter has autism
i would def be offended maybe don't play
it let's just remove it i don't want to
offend anyone there's there's enough
people here
who are saying no that i think it's a
bad idea yeah
but it's okay guys come on
we have plenty of other funny sound
bites don't don't it's fine
i asked the people and they spoke that's
it
lots of passionate
people on both sides of the
of the conversation here
there it is though okay
let's get [ __ ] is is out
and i'm no longer going to be saying
that word
let's get r worded see that's something
else that sounds so much worse
let's get our worded in here
let's get our worded in here let's get
our word
in here that's bill cosby's uh
rendition uh his anthem
[Music]
let's get uh and then another crazy
thing that i just saw this morning
um
where's the uh woody allen stuff guys
can you put that at the top
woody allen and now are stunt woody on
alec baldwin is on a speed run for
everybody to hate his guts
now as you know he accidentally
shot and killed someone on on set
recently
and that has been a huge kind of
there's been a huge investigation about
like was he at fault or uh
whatever i don't know i know a lot of
conservatives have just been like going
unfairly hard on him in my opinion just
because he's like a
he wants gun reform and they're like
well you shot and killed someone on set
well it's dumb he spent five years on
snl making fun of daddy trump too so it
was an accident i mean it's not his
fault no but i'm just the motivation
yeah
yeah they hate him they hate him hating
his guts yeah
but
i've passive on alec baldwin but this i
think i hate him after that this is
insane you guys
if anyone who's been watching long
enough i
watched the hbo documentary about woody
allen i spoke strongly
about it
and well let's just watch alec baldwin
justify this here
oh wait no there's the video guys
where's the video
right here
so he's very excited to announce
i click that there's no video
yes there is it's the first thing that
pops up
right here check it out
it's not no in discord
right here
oh
i could just put it up well it's fine i
got it now
yeah just pop it in the top of the dock
that's where i check for that all right
here we go
listen to this
tuesday
the 28th
it's the 28th i think this coming
tuesday i'm going to be doing an
instagram live at 10 30 eastern time 10
30 eastern time with
what's wrong with them
it's me
10 30 eastern time
um
i'm going to be doing an instagram live
with
woody allen
yeah of course he'll talk to you i'll
talk to anyone that will talk to him
because he's a [ __ ] child rapist
of his own daughter for christ's sake
probably do an interview with me for
god's sake he's so desperate
love i love you woody
um instagram live with woody
i just find it endlessly and incredible
that you know alec baldwin baldwin is
one of these guys who's like
die hard lib
he's probably like harvey weinstein's a
monster and all this [ __ ] and you know
uh this industry how could this industry
let this happen and here he is
interviewing now let me tell you
this let me read his caption here let me
preface this by stating that i have zero
interest and anyone's judgment and
sanctimonious posts here i'm obviously
someone who has my own set of beliefs
and could not care less about anyone's
speculation if you believe that a trial
should be conducted by way of an hbo
documentary that's your issue now listen
to what i'm going to say
this was not just an hbo documentary it
had
his ex-wife
what's her name she's
mia ferret
the the dot pharaoh whatever the [ __ ]
close enough
mia pharaoh
[Music]
and the daughter his daughter
that he r-worded
and another one of his son that
corroborated the story this is not just
an hbo documentary this is his family
including his daughter came out
and told exactly what he did to her his
[ __ ] own daughter
and not only that there was another uh
his stepdaughter that he
uh
molested and raped too it's called allen
versus pharaoh you cannot watch that and
not come out i mean there's no doubt
about it so either he's not watched the
documentary but this is just so
embarrassing man i mean you go how does
this keep happening in hollywood
here it is
i'm glad you love him a lot of people
love his work bro
he raped his own [ __ ] daughter
like a lot of times throughout her whole
childhood
i mean it's nuts with this man he is
sick
[ __ ]
lunatic and shame on you
this is insane how do you do this
and the way he's so smug about it
so smug
i mean what the [ __ ]
i don't think he's watched the
documentary i love how he goes
sanctimonious [ __ ] he raped his
daughter
and stepdaughter for decades
what's sanctimonious about that the [ __ ]
is that crazy dude i'm sorry oh yeah all
the comments are super yeah that's a big
no
no that's a hard no guess i won't be
tuning in the predator's sick you lost
us at woody
i've supported you 100 through
everything that's what i was saying like
he has a lot of supporters who have been
like i'm defending you
against all these conservative hip jobs
but
he's really going to lose everybody at
this point
um did any of you guys see this
documentary i saw it yeah it's wild it's
horrific yeah it's it's so disturbing
and like there's no doubt he did this
yeah it's all in there it's his daughter
and his ex-wife the mother of the child
it's all in there they're on record
it's so nuts
not to mention the fact
that you don't even have to mention the
fact that he married his
step-daughter
when she was like 15 or something and
that's not even in dispute
not when she was 15 that he married or
well i guess he was raising her since
she was a kid right
the dude's got a thing for [ __ ] his
kids i mean clearly and i hate this it's
disgusting but it's true it's just all
he wants to do is [ __ ] kids bro
and al baldwin's like dope let's talk
about your new book
[Laughter]
so there you have it alec baldwin has
truly fallen
well good because
i've always [ __ ] hated him so
i'm glad we can we can confidently
cancel him now or whatever his his um
his wife has some funny gossip too have
she pretended to be spanish oh
is the like most ridiculous can you find
a video
her name is hilarious baldwin hilaria
and but it's it was just what was her
name larry really just knows like
hillary something ellaria not hilarious
but
hilaria there's a video english is her
first language and there's a video of
her cutting like grabbing a cucumber or
something she's like how do you say
cucumber and it is so
so great so let me ask you this olivia
because you know about this so what what
actually was is the story here
uh okay so
born in the united states but uh i'm
pretty sure her dad or her mom
something with their job took them to
spain so she was raised in spain and in
the united states but as like her
publicity got bigger and bigger she
would
put on more of a
persona i guess and her accent was just
so inconsistent but she never she like
came out and defended herself and was
like this this is all fake but it's the
clips are like pretty damning so she's
denied it yeah i got to see these clips
the the the she's speaking fluent
english i wonder when did she move to
spain if we can give her any
hilaria baldwin
let's get into the gossip guys
here's a video called six times hilaria
baldwin's dubious spanish accent love
that on wrong on camera
let's see
she was um let me just see here
baldwin claims she was raised in spain
she has
been uh it's really nice all right let's
just watch this
you know it feels different it really
feels different but i didn't think it
was going to be different but it feels
quite different what's the thing that
surprised you the most
um i think just the fact that it feels
different you know we like to say
husband and wife a lot yeah i come
husband now say husband where are you no
he took me out to
montauk
okay so
she so she speaks perfect english and
was raised in the states well that's
what people say people are saying that
she only vacationed in spain she says
that she was raised there half of the
time but i'm pretty sure her parents
were professors
of spanish
is what i'm reading
so maybe that's like
how the ideology of like i
am came into came into play but where
did she find that i there's a whole
section on her wikipedia age in december
2020 a twitter user accused her of
impersonating a spanish accent
and a number of posts including her
contrived spanish accent including from
the today show is that what we just
watched
which yes
oh she forgot the english word for
cucumber that that is that clipper let's
watch the whole thing yeah
[Laughter]
so here you want me to go back to number
two
she was born in boston
it says and
commentators know that baldwin is often
misidentified as either
spanish or latina
encouraging positive press by hispanic
media
so she's not hispanic obviously she's
not even spanish they're they're saying
here
but i
okay let's just who gives a [ __ ] she's a
dumb wife mom
he said that was as close as he could
get to spain to my family and to rome
because we really like rome as well
and um
he got down on his knee and then i
remember the rest because i started
crying
yeah so there
sounded pretty clean yeah stay active
when i'm pregnant and it's you know i'm
not trying to stay thin i'm just trying
to keep my circulation going and
stretching and keep my muscle tone up it
was well you know what i i feel like all
of our children wear semi surprises in a
good way good surprises
like positive surprises you know i have
four kids but you have to be able to
treat each one as if they were only
child sometimes
so i have to have my individual time
with each one of them
yeah maybe that's why you wake up so
early i want my mommy time huh
[Music]
well on the on the
note of this have you seen the austin
butler videos of him with the elvis
accent still no i'd love to see that in
interviews he like still has that he's
the guy that played elvis in the in the
biopic
is that out
um it was that it like premiere just
came out this week did anybody watch
that i mean is that a thing i'm good i i
don't get elvis i don't know i i i
i don't like elvis and i i don't
i just don't get it i'm what the [ __ ]
why people agree on that i mean i get if
you're like a grandma and you're like oh
that's the first time a dude shook his
hips and ugh
but like elvis just i don't know bro
it's just not that dope
i'm
sorry it's just old [ __ ] bro and also
he's a piece of [ __ ] too his
biography's insane all those guys were
man
every dude born before like 19 or 1950
was like a [ __ ] straight up rapist
child predator yeah i literally this
weekend i was reading about elvis and
priscilla she was
14
when they met in germany is that nuts or
what
nuts
dude
bro it was a different time that's why
um guys like harvey weinstein they're
like this is [ __ ] dude this is why i
got into show business this coming
tuesday i'm gonna be doing an instagram
what was that is that me yeah you have a
video open
what why is that playing oh it's playing
again all right bye all right bring it
up so this is the guy who played elvis
let's see here
um
corner oh
sick of being a boomer and [ __ ] never
working for me
we still hear it in your voice you can
you just not shake them i keep asking
people is this my voice you know because
it feels this feels like my real
oh my gosh i love 90s grunge style red
flannels and ripped up jeans and leather
coats and stuff you couldn't be more
excited i don't know when you live with
something for two years and you do
nothing else you can't help but it
becomes a fiber of your being
we still hear it in your voice you can't
oh yeah i don't care
i hate actor i just hate actors who
they're so self-important
you're not even a real dude you played a
real dude
like
you know what i'm saying he's got
nothing on the top got nothing on the
goss man
he's got nothing on what the goss ryan
gosling oh the goss yeah well goss
wouldn't pull that kind of [ __ ] up no
goss is goated you know yeah he's goaded
you would [ __ ] ryan gosling i'm pretty
sure that i don't know if i'd [ __ ] him
do would i wear his skin maybe
you want to be him
i just want to be his friend i don't
know if i agree i feel like ryan gosling
is the type of dude to
to like keep an accent after a movie
is pretty clean i don't think the goss
has got he's done anything annoying has
he dude pgd man perfect goss dong oh my
god bro
what
play the sound bite
i'm not playing play it i'm not playing
too late now it would have been funny
okay well elvis is a [ __ ] weird dude
and i don't care about that dumbass
movie
but let's see what kind of reviews it
got i'm just curious
elvis
hey remember
hey baba oh it's bazlerman if there's
any 14 year old girls in the audience i
don't know it was a basilar's lerman
movie it got uh 79 not that bad i guess
well there you have it guys okay
went on a bit of a tangent there
speaking of musicians that i [ __ ]
hate machine gun kelly
[Music]
bro that's another thing i just don't
get it oh yeah well this is actually
interesting on um
the week afterwards check out this
interview he's doing
harvey weinstein
my story save your sanctimonious
judgment
all right harvey weinstein is one of the
most successful film producers in the
history i love his work
he's a genius a force of nature i mean
this this is essentially what's
happening and i would even submit that
what
woody allen did was even more heinous if
you can judge such things
in a bracket you know what i mean i
don't know if you if that's appropriate
but
yeah
our word to your list yeah exactly
uh and then and then he's going to be
doing um
the week after that he's going to be
doing a uh
interview from prison with kevin spacey
that'll be good
there you have it alec baldwin ladies
and gentlemen
yes
all right let's talk about machine gun
kelly
this video went viral
of him
shutting down a whole damn
wave pool in north carolina carol wins
so he could go in by himself did they
really do that
that's kind of insane that they would do
that for him
he cares he is weed man i'm i'm actually
seeing right now that people are saying
this is not true he did not shut it down
oh really what's well then why the [ __ ]
about sorry
i think we might have got got i guess i
guess look it up let's see but let's
watch this closed
and look at this
so they closed the pull down because
machine gun kelly's here
they just jacked every single person
here for one person
and think about how many people here are
not even pass holders who bought a
ticket
and like came up here
and and this is what they do they shut
the pull down
for one person so one entitled little
prick
can come here
and and they just screw everyone else
this is carowinds for you ladies and
gentlemen
one entitled little prick
i mean shut everything down isn't that
great this is what carowinds thinks
about their their paying customers
people who have to like actually like
make financial sacrifices to be here and
there he is over here a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] machine gun kelly and [ __ ] heroines
for enabling this [ __ ] kind of
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] tyrannical little [ __ ]
[ __ ] this man
[ __ ] you machine gun kelly you suck your
son suck your dork your hair sucks your
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so you could sit here could you find a
private place to sit you [ __ ] prick
yeah
i pissed in the [ __ ] way pool right
before machine gun kelly got in how do
you like that little [ __ ] how did you
like swimming in my [ __ ] piss
machine gun kelly hope you enjoyed that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
so okay now there's some we have some
alternate explanations but it sounds it
i don't know who to believe it says the
parks
attributed the pool's closing to a
poorly timed maintenance issue on the
filter
yeah i don't know about that i think
they shut it down for machine guns
they're just covering yeah yeah
i mean he wasn't in the pool
i must know it would have been way more
damning if he was in the pool by himself
just like off to the side i don't know
and the guy did say that he pissed in
the pool maybe that's why they shut it
down and he's just trying to shift the
blame yeah i mean it's pretty funny he's
like i pissed in the polls like well you
know a bunch of kids are gonna get in
there
after he's done right
but as we learned 90 of people pee in
the pool or like 80 or something
staggering
maybe i'm gonna pee in my trash can down
there i don't know over the weekend i
accidentally got a ride shut down at a
water park and it was the most
embarrassing moment of my life because
my glasses did over the weekend yeah
over the weekend where were you uh
what's it called
lina hurricane harbor
raging water oh you guys went to raging
waters yeah
interesting
yeah my glasses fell off and they
wouldn't let me jump back in the pool to
get it and they shut off the ride and
there was a forgot my sunglasses and
though this whole line was just looking
at me cussing me out they were talking
they were pissed why are you going down
a slide with your sunglasses on
i mean lots of people are doing it just
like mine fell off that just seems like
of all the [ __ ] you've done zach that
sounds weird to you yeah
i mean i'm with ab i i think
people wear sunglasses in the pool all
the time it's bright sunny yeah yeah how
they're going to shut it down just
because your sunglasses fell that's cool
because the jets were it was on a slide
and the jets were too strong so i had to
turn off the jets
and a lot of people don't know this but
it takes a long time to turn off those
jets for whatever reason so everyone
makes sense yeah and then
like 10 lifeguards came over they're all
like talking about it i'm like how much
were those glasses 250 bucks and i just
got them okay i just got them if i
didn't you were yeah those weren't 50
yeah wait if you if you cared about the
ray bans they fold wait
let's see him where you got him yeah i
got him did you go down with the
sunglasses on
you went down with the glasses on your
face
yeah he did i was surprised he stopped
it for him though because
i mean they're just sunglasses and it's
his fault for wearing them i was going
to tell him he should say they're like
prescription eyeglasses but no
they stopped the ride
and yeah they looked for it i'll tell
you why okay hold on before you guys
judge look at this look at this cute
little ray-ban case no they're [ __ ]
sick of [ __ ] open up
and they fold baby lena were you
surprised he went down with his
sunglasses i asked him before i'm like
are you gonna wear them in the ride and
he's like yeah i was surprised did you
caution him against it or you're like
well he knows what he's doing yeah i
figured he knows what he's doing right
wait did you think did your bathing suit
have like a little pocket or velcro or
something
no
okay okay you machine gun kelly that
[ __ ] i did and i was like trying to
like hide behind leno but she's shorter
than me and i was just so embarrassed
and then after they found it everyone
started clapping i'm like and then i had
to walk i had to walk past the line to
get out oh my god that is embarrassing i
still feel like i kind of deserve that
for going down the slide with sunglasses
on that's interesting counter argument
zack scott we had no place to store our
[ __ ] so they have lockers there i know
they have lockers our stuff was in the
lockers but we're already out i have
sensitive eyes zach
okay
um
zach didn't you [ __ ] on a lawn
yeah but that's neither here nor there
yeah this is this is that's here well i
feel like that um it makes a little less
it's not hearsay than going in
with sunglasses here's say your honor
it's irrelevant to this conversation
sure i just i don't know you got i i
don't know if i could go down with
sunglasses on i don't know maybe i'm
wrong
there you have it
i don't know lots of controversy here
today um how was raging waters it was
cool
um besides that incident it was fun you
guys should check out hurricane harbor
yeah that's what zach was telling me
i've never been to raging waters though
only hurricane harbor
you went to the one out in san dimas
right yes you see bill and ted bro
no i don't even know what that is
that's excellent adventure oh i didn't
watch it trains things on my foot at the
circle i know i know i've heard of it i
absolutely guarantee that that water is
like 50 kids piss in those water parks
baby did you piss on the glasses did you
pee in the pool at all no i didn't did
you pee at the water park
no
no never peed once well we got there
late we got there at three o'clock and
it was only open until six
so you showed up shut down a ride and
left exactly yeah what the hell but they
the season pass is only twenty dollars
more than just a day pass so i just
gotta see some passes we'll be back you
didn't urinate at all at your time at
raging waters no i spent an hour waiting
in line for a ride and i spent a half
hour waiting to get my glasses back why
then did you pee before you left though
i mean i may have peed i don't i don't
recall he's full of [ __ ] right now he
pissed in the pool he paced in that pool
man
no doubt
but you know what's interesting though
the bathrooms at those water parks are
so rancid because it's all wet and nasty
as [ __ ] you're better off peeing in the
pool honestly those bathrooms are
[ __ ] gnarly
oh here you go 14 and under get free
tickets that's right i forgot machine
gun kelly famously said
rock stars used to [ __ ] 14 year olds who
cares
hell yeah
hell yeah why why is the chat spamming
the [ __ ] out of pole i think they want
to take a poll if a.b peed in the pool
or or something about the glasses i
don't know yeah
i'll be a little more specific here
people um
okay excellent
very good very good very good
are you would you wear your glasses down
the slide again
i have this little thing that goes
behind it that like holds it up so maybe
i'll try
but that that i could i'll give you that
that's a little safer go a little plan a
little better next time yeah yeah just
stop by 711 and grab a five dollar pair
of sunglasses to uh rock and roll
remember this i'm watching h3
also look check this out
huge development now as you know jeff
whittick is my best buddy
i've been saying that for a year now
that we're best buds and dan always gets
mad at me because i always give him the
benefit of the doubt and i always wanted
like you know treat him nice because
he's my boy
[Laughter]
jeff whitaker's my boy
yeah you guys are tight okay ethan but
my friendship with jeff might be ending
and my best friendship with mike made
beginning here take a listen i remember
this i'm watching h3 and i'm watching
him talk about me and my situation and
then it's me sitting here and then it
goes to the next clip and he's like all
right now [ __ ] let's get to mike and
then he gets to you and you're sitting
in the same spot yeah
no and then funny because producers are
like wait is that jeff's studio actually
you know what [ __ ] jeff that might
because i interact with him on twitter
wait did we say [ __ ] jeff and mike we
may have
it sounds like something we might have
said yeah yeah yeah we we have a lot of
say a lot of things we have a lot of
opinions here
strong
opinions that's why i can't go anywhere
in l.a
guaranteed
yeah
like you know i don't know if i talked
about it like that the whole uh nelk
boys were at
posts uh listening party and that's it's
like if i'm going somewhere i guarantee
i'm gonna run in someone
that i don't want to see
we talk a lot of [ __ ]
that's true i [ __ ] my pants today but
anyway here we go yo actually you know
what [ __ ] i might because i interact
with him on twitter because i actually i
actually
ironically have a lot of similar
viewpoints him to an extent i think
that's true during the um
the uvalde thing we were liking each
other's post he was being very vocal
about
needing gun reform and and i thought
that was very refreshing to see from
another creator nice a lot of people are
just not that people on youtube or maybe
just in general they don't like sticking
their necks out for [ __ ]
uh that one's a no [ __ ] brainer
though i thought same thing with roe vs
wade i mean he's you know he's making
statements and stuff which is good
um
yeah
i think you know he ethan's pretty
he's not i wouldn't call him even close
to fringe left but he's a little bit
more left than me i think that's nice i
i don't consider myself fringe left at
all but a lot of people would throw me
under the bus and say that i'm like a
communist or a lunatic or something yeah
definitely not okay mike
looking like he's got that fouseytube
haircut by the way
well
i was gonna comment on that didn't he
recently
publicly like go to turkey for like a
hair transplant
but yeah he did get a transplant i think
it was okay good for him yeah i was just
telling chet cause they're all like what
the [ __ ] is with that hair okay i
thought he got that fouseytube tattoo or
some [ __ ]
okay good for mike he's gonna have a big
beautiful set of hair my bff it tastes
like beef jerky you know now that his
hairline
wait what
it tastes like yeah okay okay
now that his hairline is restoring it
could be a good time for us to become
friends because as you know
people with bad hair lines generally
just tend to not like me
i like you
you have no hairline dan is that okay is
that how it works yeah bow down to the
king my friend
yeah i took a hairline check for on my
37th birthday and i was like
still got it it's all i've got
but i still got you did it three years
ago should do an updated one 37th
birthday dude no i'm 37.
no i'm 37.
everyone kept wishing me a 40th happy
40th birthday by the way the fupa
troopers
it's a big year
happy 40s it would be if i was if i was
turning 40.
like 35 40.
that's actually accurate now
how old is this going 35.40
anyway let's listen to big mike my best
buddy now on certain topics or at least
the way that he presents him online you
know he's younger than you i ca i mean
whatever but
also didn't take the bait
not that i'm offended and jeff what's
wrong with you bro i uh i thought you
were bored i've always ride for you bro
what are you well what ethan looks old
okay
well at least i have two working eyes
i'm sorry though come on i somehow i
knew sorry i'm
felt it coming he jabbed i jabbed maybe
i went too low though
what but you know i don't know
but i would never say such a thing about
my best friend mike listen what i'm
trying to say is i actually interact
with them a lot because we have a strong
viewpoints that are very similar
i can't talk about that i can't talk
about this [ __ ] with you guys because
you guys are gonna [ __ ] i'm trying to
have an objective conversation let's get
a caller let's help somebody we need to
remember there you go mike
so we're best buddies now i think you
know i think there's a bridge there
and i'm hopefully i'm just wanting him
to leave logan and maybe he could
co-host our show what do you think oh
interesting maybe there's a universe
where
where uh
we could have a show together what would
your what would your frenemies uh mashup
be 37 year olds cryptos crypto bros
you know i have no problem with mike
actually the only thing that old
looking back on the stuff adults
olds
dull dulds [ __ ] dolts yeah
didn't he do some didn't we just call
him out for chilling some yeah like two
days ago
yeah that's what i got to say mike you
got it like you were besties and i love
you and all that
you got to stop with the crypto [ __ ] bro
cause that just
it's bringing you down and you're a king
and i know
i know you could be so much better i
know you could
ascend to true kingdom
but i can't be [ __ ] with you during
when you're doing that crypto [ __ ] okay
so let's talk the crypto [ __ ] maybe we
should have them call in and we could
discuss the crypto stuff and how we can
be how can we move forward with our
friendship what do you guys think that
crypto [ __ ]
i don't think he will
um accept that condition of your
friendship to be frank i think he makes
uh quite a bit of his money through
various well then
you know would you be friends with uh
you know
bernie madoff
i'm actually we're actually interviewing
him next week on instagram live
yeah would you go on a vacation on berry
madoff's yacht
but anyway i don't know um but there you
go shout out to mike he's my bestie with
an asterix with an asterix
and you know that dink doing [ __ ] i mean
come on bro you guys are up to
shenanigans over there
you guys are straight up doing financial
crimes
so while i love you and you are my
bestie this is i'm saying this in your
best favorite now was he
uh
i mean i understand why the assumption
is he did but i i seem to recall that
all being logan tink dunk was logan i
don't know but mike was there for the
ride he was there for it
by the way this is what's happening
right now
yeah i think i might have [ __ ] in my
pants yep
friendship ended with jeff he they're
you guys gonna have a big hurdle to get
through zach though you and mike are
gonna have a lot of yeah we need to have
a talk yeah yeah
i think you guys can work it out though
i think you can work it out because
um
if i recall it ended up being true the
whole [ __ ] his gym shorts thing yeah we
have proof yes yeah like zach was
talking about it for years and then mike
came out and said he he [ __ ] his gym
shorts i [ __ ] my pants today but to be
fair i have [ __ ] my pants as well but
not at a 24 hour fitness [ __ ] your
gym shorts no is that where it happened
yeah yeah that's pretty embarrassing i
know
but i'm willing to have a conversation
with him talk this out you know i'm i'm
open about my [ __ ] story we just you
know we need to clear the air wipe the
ass for this yeah okay yeah
yeah but i mean yeah
you know
there's a path there mike
my best bud
but you gotta chill in the financial
crimes okay
i frown upon that stuff in my friends
i mean but dink doing the thing is he
was along for the ride he knew what was
up because he was like yo what's his
dink dunk [ __ ] like he was he was a
useful henchman to logan on the dink
doing stuff obviously that was logan's
thing and i wouldn't blame that on on
mike
it's that recent sponsorship uh he did
that really
[ __ ] my tits so this week
so anyway shut up mike we love him
yes
we love mike
um look at get a load of this dumb [ __ ]
oan one american network these are like
fringe psycho conservative lunatics
part of the christian of she's a
christian fascist
take a look
where did she post this by the way on
instagram
imagine posting this look at a load of
this psycho [ __ ] [ __ ]
come to be greeted with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] what the hell is that
huntington beach is the town of good
old-fashioned hardworking american
people the people that worked it's
orange county dummy it's not
shut up
you're like 30 minutes from l.a shut the
[ __ ] up
all through the cold locked out yes
that's right huntington beach never shut
down any
i'm not getting the connection there
dummy
it was instagram she deleted it oh
that's good she's so she was shamed off
that's awesome even in her psychotic
christian fascist
following
she couldn't deal with it shame
just imagine how emboldened these people
feel though where they can straight up
feel comfortable posting this publicly
um
we did never shut down
for covet and now they're flying
gay pride flags during pride month
i don't get it
the hell is
this flying together in that american
flag the disgrace to our city and take
it down immediately whoever the hell is
running this town needs to be fired make
america great again make huntington
beach
dude you huntington beach is not like a
lost class neighborhood no it's super
high
very expensive yeah i've looked it up
it's it's on the higher scale of uh
household income for um or median income
for california i mean huntington beach
is like a weird place it's right south
of l.a but it's like a bastion of
conservatives conservatives live there
lots of maga people there but they're
all rich as [ __ ] white people it's just
orange county in general uh is
pretty conservative for california less
so than it used to be um but it it still
leans right but how incredible is this
that you feel that emboldened to post
something so openly homophobic i mean
shame on you
i've been so block-pilled recently i
just don't give a [ __ ] anymore this
lady's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] her like i'm just i'm sorry she is
i agree with you this is vi i take this
as violence now it is it i mean [ __ ] you
[ __ ] uh get
just [ __ ] off go away forever
um you're not fit to live in society
sorry
[ __ ] you thank you jordan backing me up
and you know i'm not playing nice with
these [ __ ] clown these fascists
anymore i'm just not i've been doing a
series of tweets by the way
i'm taking down each supreme justice uh
supreme court justice taking them down
one at a time
all of them who voted
to repeal rover suede
have you been enjoying them dan what was
your thoughts
um do you like the series or no oh well
i like the series when the one popped up
where you were like this crazy-eyed
[ __ ] yeah bob
i was like
i'm just like
that one but she is
she is committing violence on women
massive skills she sucks the worst thing
is me calling her a crazy-eyed [ __ ]
what about the thousands of women are
they're gonna die as well i'm not trying
to defend her christian family you know
people get well they can people got
sensitive [ __ ] dick calling people
yeah good yeah get mad
get mad we drank beer you know what i
mean get mad
you should get mad
your body belongs to the state this
rapist named brady cavanaugh lol so that
was my first one
as you know he voted to repeal uh ro
and then of course uh this
now she's she really scares the [ __ ] out
of me if you know have you guys seen
hands mate entail because she is this
character
i haven't seen it but i have so much
hate for that she is so disgusting
this character in handmade entail
she helped like built this uh society
where women are uh systematically raped
and
um
are second-class citizens subservient
and she helped build this this world so
she's kind of like uh
gender traitor i don't know that's a
thing not of a
female ally no
so i said this crazy-eyed [ __ ] lied to
congress about her intentions to
overturn roe v suede
she's a christian fascist who hates her
own gender i'm sure if she was raped by
a family member she'd be first in line
for abortion though
sure would be
and by the way when you have a supreme
court that's openly lying to congress
about what they're going to do how much
credibility do they have left let's be
real this woman she's supposed to be
by she's supposed to be above politics
she went from the supreme court and
[ __ ] lied and said it's settled law
she
how why should i give a [ __ ] about a
supreme court justice that lies in front
of congress
openly and intentionally
um
i'm so angry about this [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] up you guys
oh yeah i keep getting reported by the
way i get these emails all the time now
we've received complaints uh regarding
your account
i got one for
bratty boy and uh
the coney barrett one yeah nothing
happened though so i posted it i said
keep reporting me [ __ ] losers
this is one i posted this morning this
is our boy alito
got a look at this guy
voted to overturn roe
in 2005 this goofy-headed [ __ ]
wrote that an officer couldn't be
charged for performing a strip search on
an innocent ten-year-old girl
that's true there was a big ruling he
and most of the justices voted that he
could be prosecuted
they took the mom and a child the police
they were not suspected of any crime
they were not on the search warrant and
they strip searched the mom and 10 year
old girl
and they wanted to sue the officers and
this guy says you can't sue the officer
for that it's qualified immunity
he's a simp for police
he's a goofy-faced [ __ ] freak
he said if he if he won't protect girls
from power hungry pedophiles then why
would he care about women's rights to
have an abortion [ __ ] you alito
there you have it
there it is all
i mean these guys wow
it's crazy it's it's so crazy
so insane
it's really happening you know like the
darkest chapter in american history we
never dreamed that it could ever come to
this and here we are
trump managed to get three justices in
one crazier than the next
you know brett kavanaugh is now
considered the swing vote like he's the
moderate one did you know that
he he gave he brett kavanaugh that's the
moderate one so to speak who roberts
oh yeah but i've i swear he was the one
that actually well now he's the liberal
one right he was a bush appointee but he
he voted no on those i know because he's
[ __ ] actually like
he's like a real judge
he's done lots of bad [ __ ] over the
years too
but
at least he got that one right but brett
kavanaugh's is being hailed as the swing
justice because he said while i believe
that roe versus wade
should be thrown out
i do think it should be illegal for
states
to prosecute people for traveling to
other states to get an abortion
so there you have it
that's the liberal take that's a we
drank beer
very low bar
which is like literally an insane like
you bro i don't
i can't do it yeah but these these
[ __ ] animals
are gonna destroy our country there was
one that came out this morning that was
shocking what was it
oh i just read about this morning too
what was it um oh god what was it let me
check the news
another shitty one like it's all bad
oh yeah
oh yeah they said
this was a great one
supreme crew court rules overturning
long-standing
precedent
that teachers
and public you know people who serve in
public positions
can lead prayer in school
leading prayer in school guys
um
this is [ __ ] nuts
this is actually it's interesting though
because this is actually their plan to
stop the school shootings
more prayer yeah that could have that
could help in the school well more or
less more prayers there's been so much
thoughts and prayers and it obviously
isn't working and so they really they
hit the books and
analyze the situation deeply and they
realize the prayer is happening in the
wrong
uh location
it needs to be happening in the school
itself in order to appreciate
yeah put up your um your faith shield
yeah well now that this has happened
let's see if school shooting stopped
let's just dance give it a chance
and of course they ruled along party
lines six to three
they're just overturning long-standing
tradition and the reason why this is so
[ __ ] up is one
you know who they're they're talking
about christians if you're not a
christian
you're gonna be ostracized you're gonna
feel like you have to participate it's
going to be weird there's supposed to be
a separation of church and state that is
fundamental to this country that they
are eroding intentionally
and lying about it now what happens when
uh you know
the the muslim guys go out there and
leave prayer
that's that's not gonna fly there's no
[ __ ] way bro because it's a christian
fascist country
there should not be prayer in public
schools period
yeah but there you go the supreme court
says you can pray now
uh
teachers can
can lead a prayer
so there you have it
all right um
we should do our ad and then also it is
two o'clock so we should um do the ad
and then move on to the thing with your
mom what i should do is show you this
real fast so okay
accomplished this
i don't know how he pulled it off man
[Music]
you really did it bro you made it happen
close the trunk that's pretty nuts right
that's not much better
what you know that's an impersonator
that's totally oh no i thought it was
really her it looked so much like her
it's like
it's tick-tock
no i thought it was really her it looks
so don't you think it looks like her i
mean i [ __ ] like her but i don't
think that's her
yeah you're right it doesn't make sense
she's on she's big on tick tock it's
like tick tock kris jenner
watch it one more time
knowing the
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now listen to
actual curses close the trunk
mud
you got chris [ __ ] i got zonked yeah you
want to come to my you got criss cross
[ __ ]
damn
all right let's think we have one
sponsor today let's thank them it's
stamps you know them you love them
i love stamps.com whether you're running
a small business
when you're running a small small
business every second counts you can't
afford to waste a single moment so why
are you still taking time out of your
day
to go to the post office when you could
be using stamps.com instead
stance.com makes mailing and shipping
quick easy and cost
effective
we've talked about a lot of times uh
dan's girlfriend uses stamps.com she
does for her home business that's right
she's got
uh the little uh digital scale that
connects to a computer and there's like
an app and you know you get your package
put it on the scale weighs it figures
out the postage prints out a little
thing you slap it on there the little
sticker boom bang they pick it up your
uncle you don't even have to think about
it don't even have to talk about it dude
such a great service that not only
is it cheaper
30 off usps rates and 86 percent off ups
rates
because they get bulk discounts because
they get so much you know mail
you also don't have to go they come to
your house and pick it up my god
unbelievable it's a no-brainer for 20yrs
stamps.com has been indispensable for
over 1 million businesses it gets
stamps.com gives you access to the post
office and ups shipping services you
need right from your computer
all you need is a regular computer and
printer no special supplies or equipment
you're up and running in minutes
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere you want
plusdance.com seamlessly works with
shopify amazon etsy ebay and more
so whether you're an office descending
invoices an etsy shop
sending your product or warehouse
shipping out orderstamps.com is your
mailing and shipping solution
stop wasting time and start saving money
when you use stamps.com to mail and ship
sign up at stamps.com
h3tv for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale there is no long-term
commitments or contracts go to
stamps.com
h3 thank you
love you
here's your tv
all right let's get my mom in here let's
do something a little lighter
uh in the meantime i guess i'll just
read it uh kyra donated 10 and said can
i get a birthday shout out for her dad
who's also named ethan and is a big
leftovers fan
we're getting the the dad demo
shout out to dad everybody to ethan
ethan
um
so again i gotta pee okay so guys just
hang out for one sec i'll be right back
but we're are we getting my mom in the
room right now i sent her the link and
then our uh our donark is uh has already
joined they're in the waiting room so
i'll uh wait for donna so i'm just gonna
go go pee and then we're gonna get
started with this riveting exciting game
be right back we're gonna get it started
huh
let's get it started
don't olivia
no stop it
[Music]
that was the clean one oh just the
fergie singing that note is just so
funny
oh my god
it was a different time it was a
different time
uh
melissa donated 20 and said you guys
should check out the board eight yacht
club restaurant in long beach wait it's
in long beach
that's no longer accepting
cryptocurrency
[Music]
fiat only baby
fiat only at this crypto restaurant
it's in long beach maybe we should check
it out maybe make a fun little segment
yeah
uh
good good looking out on that i i had
heard about that but for some reason i
thought it was in new york but maybe
there's multiple i don't know
maybe um
i think there's restaurants in new york
let's see what else we got yeah
[Music]
uh happy belated 40th birthday king we
love you
soon is that suna sooner
the artist that made the animation the
animator
wasn't her name sooner
i don't recall if it is you
thanks for the birthday wish i'll pass
that along to ethan
and i guess even if it's not thank you
anyways
uh i just found out last week that my
first name
challenge challenge
literally translates to let's go
i've never been more proud
challenge
let's go challenge let's go
oh
no
dabs are the don arcs um
you know i don't know if what's going on
with uh donna she has uh
still not joined
you want me to text her we're cool
i mean i that's what i'm doing right now
i'm texting her
i know but maybe if i just do you think
she's ignoring my text but she'll answer
she really likes me hmm interesting
interesting theory there
uh could you wish jocelyn a happy
birthday thank you for twenty dollars
jocelyn
happy birthday jocelyn
thank you zach little
alley-oop there
i'm always saying this but james hoffman
is the actual youtube hairline king
sorry what
the [ __ ] is james hoffman
who the [ __ ] is james hoffman
uh-oh
it's not as good as ethan's it is a nice
airline but
james hoffman huh
mods burn whoever said that yeah banned
them
james had the appearance of a thick mat
of hair
[Music]
uh nathan says just got my rap training
cards can't wait to build my dan
commander deck hell yeah let's go
oh
mono red go mono red for the dan deck
all right
let's do it
um your mom is uh oh not here my ass i
might call her okay
[ __ ] baby no
this is all her idea by the way she knew
this dude
she was the one who was pushing for this
and not only that she kept reminding me
about it too
she's a no-show
does uh does our contestant win by
default if she doesn't show
that's a good question
you guys want to look at james hoffman
you know what we're live by the way just
so you know
okay you know what i you're gonna
laugh at this but because i have the new
phone i
never
installed the app
for
zoom calls so i was just trying to do
that and you know they don't let you
see what you're typing so every time i
type in my
code it says it doesn't match you mean
because it's you mean like the password
is blurred out yeah yeah yeah
putting in a password and then it says
okay do it again and i do it and it
keeps on saying it doesn't match so how
many times have we tried that
three okay three
should i wait on the phone we're just
basically waiting on you so i'll just
wait if you want to go ahead and give it
another shot
just take just take your time okay one
more time yeah take your time on that
just make sure you get those
those right
is there any tricky ones in there like
symbols read the password out live while
you're uh typing something tricky about
it it's just okay
i i don't know it's
this phone is really sensitive like if
you get too close to
another number
you know what i mean sure you gotta you
gotta be precise but you know if you
push it you can see what letter you push
that's what i'm trying to do here it is
[Music]
next
damn it
it won't what the heck so so you're
typing in your password or your
verification code
my verification from the password why
don't you just copy
verification from the password is it the
second password to make sure the first
page matches
yeah what uh
are you creating a new account what
screen are you on let's start there
[ __ ] thanks what do you mean
i don't know
but my phone screen is it just the login
page or or something else
well i started with going to download
the app okay right good start yep that
makes sense so far
so far i'm with you
cute
keep going so you're done frustrating
yeah
yo that she just did the
keem sound bite yeah
so frustrating okay
all right well unfortunately um
it's kind of not the best time for me to
do tech support for you maybe
i mean we could maybe can we just do it
with me talking to you
um
oh no that wouldn't be ideal would it
it'd be definitely better if we could
get her yeah it'd be better but yeah you
know i do have 35 000 people watching
live so not the best time to do tech
support
so
i don't think you need to log in on the
app i just downloaded it and you can
just join me
kind of confuse me as well
you don't have to log into zoom so so
i'm getting can you send her the link
just try clicking home in a few minutes
okay hold on hold on hold on i'm getting
intel that you don't need to log in so
we're going to send you the link just
click the link okay
all right all right we're going to click
the link
okay
that's what i thought i clicked before
click here right that's the link
so maybe she didn't have it installed
click the link it took her to the
download page and then she thought she
needed to log in but now that it's on
her phone i think she's getting it
safari cannot open the page because the
address is invalid okay hold on we'll
send you a new link right dan
sure
okay we're sending a new link and then
it's telling me to download from the app
store
don't worry about that just send the
link
there's going to be a new link there
okay
so
we're gonna click that
okay i'm clicking it
here we go again it says safari cannot
open the page because the address isn't
bad
okay i think she doesn't have zoom on
her phone she's clicking the link
when it opens it sees that the app isn't
there it's redirecting her to the app
store i think the password that she's
being asked to type in is her apple id
password apple
password
the app
to down the app download the app
password someone else did it for me i
did it with you and i told you to write
it down she should be written down i
remember we did it in your computer room
and you exp explicitly told you write
this down if she has face id on her
phone it should just instantly download
well we need yeah when you download an
app you need the
password um
[Music]
we could um so many passwords it's crazy
we could
if this is not working we could hunt
this to wednesday and oh my god she
loves your hair sam
thank you tell her i said thank you so
much he's on the other side okay
apple password okay okay good good good
good now why don't i why don't i leave
you
maybe to work workshop that for a moment
and then and then you just let me know
if you fix it okay
all right so what should i do just
contact you on our just call me
[Music]
yes so download the app and then use
your
apple id
to download the app and then try to
click the link correct okay okay i'll
try it right now
all right yeah just give me a call i'm
not busy or anything i can help more
help
oh god all right i'm gonna do it right
now okay all right bye
there you have it guys mom
who famously took uh what 15 minutes to
or something to attach an email
or an image to an email
all right well we got more time to watch
other stuff for example
o.j simpson's take on roe versus wait i
love when oj weighs in on [ __ ] man it
makes me so happy
truly
my tweet my opinion
i'm blocked by oj by the way right yeah
happy sunday
well it's i am against murder don't get
me wrong
but babies aren't alive yet
my twitter sites was my opinion let's
start with roe versus wade i thought it
was a horrible decision i think women
should have
the right to decide uh uh what happens
uh with their bodies especially uh what
about when you when their necks their
heads get cut off should you i guess did
she have a right to this side would that
happen okay
a based take from o.j
i i believe a woman should have a right
to decide
if she has her head cut off or not
anyway by the way you know don't you
guys oj did it let's not even let's not
even pretend like come on at this point
he wrote a book called i did it if i did
it if i did it
yeah and he lost his civil law the man
did it okay
come on especially in cases of
rape and um and incest i'm a little
surprised that some of these alleged
evangelical women who uh have been
speaking out against you know i guess
abortion look if you believe in god you
should know mom figured it's gonna come
whoa that was fast
she's in the lobby damn that was super
fast
did we finish that video or did we get
the gist um yeah whatever it's oj let's
get let's get back in with my mom all
right i'm gonna let her in right now
hello
and we'll see how it goes
all right guys my mom has figured it out
and she's coming in
connecting
drum roll please
is my mom connected to zoom the answer
is
all the way from
woodland hills los angeles
donna
cline coming in at
about
60 something
does anyone know the exact age of their
parent that's kind of like yeah exactly
right
it's blurry we have video we're still
waiting on audio we have video
uh the one and only oh this is the best
part
but this is the best part they're
waiting on the audio yeah this is the
best [ __ ] part
new thumbna new emojis are being
generated at this moment
and
the drum roll please whoa what was that
what happened there
she startled herself keep going a little
bit of a jump scare there
here we go
you're still waiting my mom who this is
her idea by the way okay
she said let's do a segment where i call
in
and she is
currently trying to get her audio
and still not connected on the audio
[Music]
okay
do you guys do you know how frustrating
it is trying to help my mama [ __ ] you
can only imagine oh she's gone and she's
gone she got a new phone recently and
you can imagine
i wish i had known the insanity because
i didn't even i mean we've she zoomed in
a number of times at this point in
recent memory and it went relatively
smoothly
yeah i don't know she got a new phone a
while ago or like a month okay i see
that her audio is connected but both her
video and uh wait she's back we got her
no no i don't hear her oh there she is
you don't hear me oh i hear you i know
we got you we got it we got it we got it
oh my god well mom you you've done the
impossible you've connected via zoom the
congratulations how are you feeling
oh frustrated but at least i did it you
did a little lame
well you achieved the impossible
mom you you maybe
uh set your oh there's dad in the back
uh is he dad came back he was at the doc
can you just promise uh not to get an a
into a
like semi-violent altercation lover's
quarrel
like last time please
yes dad dad's gonna do his own thing he
just came back from the dentist
bring him out let's say let's see what's
wrong with his teeth
nothing he just needed to go for a
checkup why did you go there it was just
a regular checkup it's just a follow-up
visit
sounds angry even he sounded kind of
angry it's just hot he's just hot
can you can you lean the phone on
something there so yeah yeah yeah yeah
just to get a little that's good that's
good now what's in front of you you've
got notes or those butterfly notes
no
oh
what was that donna
tell you i have to tell you
look at this you see this
i'm just throw i just threw that on the
floor okay i
i
had to brush up on some things because i
thought oh my god what is if i you know
i forget some stuff i'm okay with cheat
sheets no google obviously no google
no
well you're on your phone now so i trust
that you there's no funny business well
and we were gonna we're gonna give a 30
second time limit on
the answers to these questions which
judging from
the process of setting up the zoom i
don't know if google would be that
helpful in a 30 second time frame and
not especially with her that's what i'm
saying yeah she needs five minutes
plus the google stuff mom
yes you're obviously feeling very good
this was your idea to challenge us to a
butterfly trivia contest so so you're
feeling pretty confident with your
knowledge of butterfly trivia is that
right well you know i thought so but
you know when i when i heard you guys
talking about how you were looking up
obscure things i thought not obscure not
obscure uh just just you know
listen just your standard issue uh
monarch butterfly trivia if you're if
you're uh you know
if you're
yeah i think let's see we'll we'll get
we'll cut to the
the heart of it here
um
now i i haven't let in our uh
our guest who donna is championing yet
should i um bring him in so mom we're
going to let in your champion now
and for every um you can let him in dan
okay and for every right question you
get this person gets 25 so there is some
pressure
on you mom
i i want to
win money for someone now who do we have
on the call here today we have here i'm
going to uh just add the pins so we have
a little side by side one second uh nick
are you there it's nick
hi there
there he is nick welcome to the show
now
it's all out of your hands at this point
but uh there's 250 dollars on the line
or actually there's 12 questions so even
more oh three hundred dollars frankly
300
so that could be 300 nick do we what
does this three hundred dollars mean to
you to put a little pressure on my mom
uh
it i mean three hundred dollars three
hundred dollars oh yeah that's like 500
some canadian probably so
um let's go
let's go
let's go from there all right big money
big money
now nick i understand you're a fan of my
mom are you a don arc nick
i'll have to be honest i think my
girlfriend might be more of a don arc
than me well then get out of the frame
and bring her on
she can come in she's just shy
hi what's your name
emily emily's the real dawn arc now now
who's gonna get the money are you guys
gonna split it up or what's going on
here
what's mine is hers
oh okay all right actually let's see
okay
but it is his yeah but he noticed he
didn't take mine right yeah but yes it
will be going to my email address yeah
yeah
what was your name again uh the the
lovely uh your lovely girlfriend
emily emily
so emily you are a dawn arc is that
right
i am yeah yeah i tweeted that donna a
couple times oh she's even tweeted at
you mom do you want to say anything to
uh
to our contestants here yeah big don
arks
um actually
and some milkweed
tons of milkweed she says tons of milk
yeah yeah did you have a question for
her
[Applause]
emily
oh me um i actually just wanted to i was
wondering i'm an artist
and i did this print with donna in mind
oh
that is a beautiful monarch drawing oh
my goodness and i wanted to show her and
i wanted to know if i could send it to
her oh
that is just beautiful
my mom's audio is kind of cutting out
but we'll get we'll get you her address
uh oh yay
after the call
wow that's so thoughtful well emily
we're all rooting for you obviously
and um
well here we go both of you guys are you
guys ready to basically just sit i mean
real quick yeah before we launch it
apparently we have an intro we got a
little we got all right presentation
here so
wow look at this
wow
butterfly brainiac quiz now here we are
oh that was beautiful let's go
all right guys well let's get hyped
let's get excited we're about to begin
[Applause]
300 on the line
all right
can uh can you pull up theirs too so i
can see both of them are you going to
switch side by side
here uh there you go yeah
first question to you mom
okay
a monarch's butterfly's tongue is called
a what
a proboscis wow
no hesitation
no hesitation
no hesitation
ask art
questions wow oh she's getting cocky now
okay well well that's 25 for the
beautiful couple there
you guys how you guys feeling that's 25
dollars in your pocket
oh that was a good start yeah
yep good
yes
all right
did i mention that if you get it wrong
they lose the money
no
just kidding
all right let's move on the next
question here we go
mom feeling good after last question
feeling confident
let's go question number two
monarch butterflies are poisonous
what is the poison called that is stored
in their body
which causes predators to vomit if eaten
check your notes
god i don't know i mean it's just the
milkweed that they eat
um
your answer is milkweed
yeah
well mom you came out swinging but
unfortunately that is incorrect
the correct answer is cardiac glycosides
[Music]
so
there it is
well you got you were cocky at the top
and the second one threw you for a loop
but look okay we have plenty of more
questions okay don't feel too defeated
tell me
cardiac glycosides in case you get asked
again
which does come from milkweeds just to
be clear
so so they pros
well she she knew what she was talking
about she just she lacked the technical
knowledge right which is kind of what
we're here to test right mom
[Music]
that's
obscure but okay whatever okay well they
only get harder from here
uh-oh
okay mom question number three
how far
does the monarch butterfly migrate south
2500 miles ooh
that is close to what we have can i get
it well hold on uh go ahead mom you want
to rationalize that
[Music]
well you know if you're east of the
rockies and you have to go to canada and
then you go to mishawakan it's about
2500 miles
go i'm gonna go to the judges the panel
what do you guys think is that uh what's
the written answer the written answer is
3 000 miles oh come on that's not
correct if you google it
i'll bet you that'll they'll say 2 500.
does anyone want to dispute on this
uh
yeah you knew
you were in the right area i'm going to
give it to you that's 50
how are you feeling guys how are we
feeling over there
the butterfly is
spraying i think we're in good hands we
got a master
i'm seeing both 2 500 and 3 000 wow okay
i'm just thinking i'm sure it varies
yeah it's not super precise she
knew yeah thank you let's go
hi now you guys got 50 bucks what are we
doing with the 50 bucks you guys got
plans over there
pizza pizza man
what kind of pizza you guys get
oh we we get like place we we we don't
really have what do you put on wearing
that so
oh i'm a big pineapple
um
you know what your pizza is is
underrated uh thank you
spicy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the tv is too loud is that what's going
on there watching the game in the video
what's the trunk what's he watching
there mom
he's actually watching us
oh is that right okay got it well that's
sweet but dad you're gonna have to turn
it down
you can hear me talking to you dad you
gotta turn down the tv
you always listen with the tv too loud
okay now i'm gonna do a test guys cover
your ears i'm gonna see if i can hear me
through my mom's phone
[Music]
i didn't hear it maybe it's low enough
she's giving me a little bit more
sorry everybody maybe that wasn't worth
it
um okay moving on to the next question
uh here we go here we go
here we go here we go
during the monarch butterfly's 3 000
mile migration south
they can travel
up to how many miles per day
um
they can travel
like
200 miles a day
that seems to be somewhat of an over
estimate
there have been some that have been i
mean have flown that much
so how do you how do you know that
what are we what are we measuring here
well they they tag them
they tag them
butterflies that have traveled she is
absolutely correct the record is 265
miles in one day damn
how does it cover that much ground
that's right well we have 100 miles here
but you sure know your stuff they they
they um they'll make pit stops and then
they'll continue but
yeah they've traveled pretty far
incredible isn't it
we're gonna give that as a w huh there
you go that's three right that's right
all right backing up that
all right here we go
how can you tell a male monarch
butterfly apart from a female
they have dots on their bottom wings and
females don't
okay and they're there there's another
way to indicate
but i'll i'm gonna accept that answer
yeah that's one of two ways but yeah and
the second the second one is the females
have black scales along their wing veins
i don't know if you're aware that
yeah but it's it's really hard to tell
you have to look at the dots
i gotta say she's an expert folks she
knows her stuff
calling that four to one so far you guys
want you have any encouraging words for
my mom as she uh competes for your
guys's
prosperity
float like a butterfly slow like
hey ethan can i interject one thing
go ahead
i did a a podcast for a young man the uh
this morning
and my mom is doing other
ethan this is this is um i hate the out
donna here but this is a cameo thing
because he he sent me a request on cameo
to say something wait how did you end up
with someone's podcast mom what does
that even mean not a podcast it was a
cameo didn't you say podcast she said
podcast yeah you said you were sorry i
meant cammy oh you're okay mom she's out
here plugging her cameo no no no no no
this was very interesting this was part
of the cameo request was like say
something on air
oh you really got you're taking that
you're taking you're not saying that
you're taking kickbacks to say it on air
oh my god
didn't say anything about on-air now
zach
this is absolutely corrupt hold on mom
is this why you wanted to do this quiz
in the first place because it came out
of the blue
the guy sent me a
cameo
and this morning i answered him he
didn't say anything about doing it on
air
jack
i got a cameo request and an instagram
message from this person
asking to beg his girlfriend to take him
back say something on here yeah yeah
mike mine didn't say anything about
onions
my cameo was horrible by the way what'd
they ask you to do they asked me to
apologize to his girlfriend who recently
broke up with him and i was like yo i
usually don't do cameos like this but he
asked me to say this if he's a good guy
maybe give another chance but if not no
i'm taking this this dumb ass money nice
that's a good that's the good policy
ethan
he would not have said this to me
because how would he know i was even
going to be on your show today there's
now she's innocent the times don't match
up yeah she said she broke up with me
yesterday and zach dude what did they
what did they request of you young
zachary
you say that again what did they request
of you they wanted me to uh um uh sway
her into taking this gentleman back and
did you do it no i turned it down i
didn't feel like he's doing it right now
actually he gained you hardcore but to
defend donna i i apologize that that is
true he wouldn't have known that
now mom how do you know this guy's a
good guy maybe he did horrible things to
her
to come out here and and advocate for
him he i mean he it might be harvey
weinstein for all we know
well
i i was assuming the best in in in uh
you know a human being that he was
broken-hearted
and you know he loved the girl he wanted
to ask her to
forgive him it's a little don't you
think
well did you get you already got paid
right so that's good
but here this is a little pathetic don't
you think to to
hold on if your girlfriend broke up with
you
and then you bring a video you think
it's just a gag
well i was more so gonna
point out that this this young man is
likely a fan of the show how else would
he so might be like watching right now
they they watch every show together
until they broke up what can i do about
that well you call him pathetic and a
loser well i'm sure there are pathetic
people that watch the show
i mean there's a lot of people that
watch i'm trying to be i'm just trying
to be
let me finish my thoughts okay okay
throw me under the bus i'm not throwing
you under the bus i was trying to help
you from getting stopped the bus before
it crashes i can't say that one person
who watches the show you can say
whatever you want i just well i was
trying to do and then you and then
you you threw me right under the bus
carry on no no no i was i was i was the
crossing guard making sure you got
you know across the road safely without
getting hit by the bus close the trunk
well you kind of guided the bus towards
me though it's what you're like my
relationship look at us actually you're
like the worst crossing guard ever who
said come hit this kid crossing the
street and spare me
now don't you think it's a little
pathetic that um
he's asking everybody for videos to get
his girl back that's cringe and pathetic
as [ __ ] what [ __ ]
dude i think dude i think it's over bro
i'm sorry i don't think cameos are going
to change it that's all i'm saying
i got one from him too
he paid that 24 hour price too so it's
double i turned it down too i didn't
feel comfortable doing it well now she
knows
but but my advice to you dude is that it
is a little sad
and i think that it's probably just
weird that you're doing this i don't
think it's going to help
i think you're going to get i think you
could give her some space and i but
you're going and getting celebrities
that don't know you to beg to cut i mean
it doesn't work like that
but mom you you disagree you think this
is going to work
well i don't know that it would it works
but obviously
in my the way i took it is that he cared
about this young lady and he was just
trying to figure out anything he got to
get a hold of this girl donna did was it
also 24 hour for you too
it was damn this dude spent it bank man
yeah he did
no i think he was sincere why would he
of course he's sincere but he's this is
not this is not healthy this is not a
healthy activity it's a winning strategy
to get no what would you want to say
olivia
i said i'll try to get yeah i want to
talk to the girl let's find out what's
up or interested yeah i'm in i'm in i'm
invested now uh send me a dm
oh boy
i'm just saying it's yeah yeah
it's my blow up in his face now to the
beautiful couple do you guys have any
advice for uh this young man who's
who's uh looking to reunite with his
his ex
i don't know it kind of sounds like
jessica just kind of wants to you know
fly her own migratory path you know
that's right that's right it's not easy
that's right that's that's well stated
to keep it on theme there thank you
oh boy
oh well well anyway
everybody's on cameo if you guys need
any
special requests you can find out
everybody there
hey do you have any other cameo messages
you want to um
shout out before we move on
i thought
you know
because
believe it or not i sent him a cameo
message and i was trying to give him
some advice and then i thought you know
i'm going to redo this and send him a
better message because
you know i was being a little
mom i i hate to break it too but he's
messaging us and he's angry
that we
that that you may have outed him live
he said it was a private request
and we outed him live mom
oh
no
i really
don't don't feel bad me and zach were
the ones being mean i said you don't
feel bad it's not on donna it's on me
and maybe yeah yeah
uh you out there
my friend
yes it's bad
i'm sorry i didn't i didn't know it was
private well to be fair he messaged me
on instagram could you say something on
air
oh well well there you go
he actually asked me to do it in insta
he i never got a cameo request you
wanted me to do it for free
to say it on air oh
his money on everyone else ian and he
went to you for the free [ __ ]
what that's what it sounds like yeah it
does sound like doesn't the cameos also
become public when you post them
some of them
you can send them to private wait can
you follow
me
are any of those public can you dig up
some of the my
my mom made one and then and abe made
one mine's mine's private oh what the
hell bro with a person requesting it
they set whether they want it to be a
private language no i thought abe the
the provider
no that's yeah that's right ethan yeah
yeah oh so he set it to private
no no no no no no no you you
so let's say he sent the cameo to me so
a b
you have the power to share it with us
all right
let's see what you did ab
and mom you too we gotta see it we gotta
follow this story all the way through
you know
in all fairness i just said their first
names i mean
who could know who that is except for
themselves for her
and him and and and i was trying to be
nice he never said anything to me about
posted publicly so i thought you know
how thrilling it would be that the girl
would see how much he cared about her
that i was so basic so so what's your
response maybe just like fu buddy i did
you a favor and now you're you're
whining no
no
i don't
whatever
there it is man this is just crazy turn
of events
do we have any of those videos to watch
before we move on i'm not going to post
mine it uh because that was
although i think it's public isn't it
you can set it on different finding out
i got to get that video guys i'm in too
deep
and if you're watching if if if you're
his girlfriend you definitely know who
you are
please message us on discord oh god
olivia
i'm sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
oh
lord oh here's the message oh my god
okay joel my god we shouldn't share that
because that's private oh [ __ ] what do
you guys think i got the message from
you no because i'm not trying to ruin
this guy's life he's a fan and we love
him i'm just giving him some advice
but wow
it sounds like
yeah
he loved her man nick and emily let this
be a lesson if you guys ever break up
don't message one of us
yeah yeah this is not a good idea to
message us
uh but but it sounds like he he sounds
like a nice guy who's just in love and
he got his heart broken so there it is
you know
there it is yeah
damn
shame eh
anyway
back to the butterflies
you never know what's going to happen
here that's the beautiful thing like the
butterfly's path to mexico
he can get flown this way in that yeah
but ultimately
always arrives at his destination or
starves to death in the wrong place
does that ever happen do they should get
off course and starve mom
um well if they can't find nectar
they need that to power up or they can't
make the the uh there's a lot of things
that can happen to butterflies in fact
the the butterflies that do the
migrating they live the longest and
that's because they don't reproduce but
man their mortality rate is super high
oh so we're not so let's be like one of
the lucky few
butterflies that arrives at the
destination
and is it either starved to death
violently eaten by a bird
there's all kinds of predators how do
what what's the different ways that
butterflies die
well
um they can get a um a disease
actually it's called o e it's a
protozoan uh parasite
and that's one number one killers right
now for monarchs um
they you know it's kind of like you know
like a tick or a ring worm and it's a
parasite and they feed off of the
monarch and they they die the uh you
know the caterpillar will will eat the
spore and it'll go inside it and then
kill it
and they're all over their their uh
their bodies sometimes and
let's avoid that
yep and then there's tachnid flies
and there's wasps and there's birds and
there's ants there's oh my god ev
they're dying all over the place all
right let's go to the next question you
ready mom
i'm ready
i believe we're at what 200 now or no
it's uh 75 this is the fifth no no uh
i answered three questions correctly
yeah 75.
no no
chance
i got two it's four to one right now
yeah no there's only been four questions
she got three right
then i got three right she's been five
she's gonna be
four right yep she's four to one i've
been keeping score oh yeah you're right
you're right you're right okay mom here
we go where do monarchs get their name
from
the monarch butterfly
uh question
there was a king
uh and he was um
known as the prince of orange oh my god
she knew it
you didn't even know about the prince of
orange who is that
yet he lives on in my mom's memory
prince of orange ladies and gentlemen
wow
also accepted prince william of one i
thought
she's when she said king i was like yep
i thought oh oh oh
okay but no no king all right here we go
question number seven
here we go
what butterfly family
do monarchs belong to
thank you zach
one more time she seems stumped or it's
frozen
is it frozen
and wait i think it's frozen i was like
wow she's really
pensive
that is a frozen screen my friends
it's a good shot though it is nice it's
nice but it's a little unsettling
[Laughter]
oh that's so funny not uh disconnected i
thought we got her with one and but but
i'm not quite sure
maybe this is a trap so she's looking
over her notes right now oh she would
she she wouldn't cheat she wouldn't do
that yeah honorable um okay she's just
yeah she disconnected so um i should i'm
sure she'll be right back let me uh okay
oh there she is
she's back she's back
all right did you get the question mom
we're on pause all right ready here it
is
what butterfly family do monarchs belong
to
the
their lepidoptera
leba doctor deez nuts
a doctrine is it inappropriate that
these notes come off yeah
very
actually that's incorrect
i'm sorry to tell you uh it is
nymphalidae
enfolida nymphala day nimpo a day
nymphalade
are you sure
um
no we're not sure we just looked all
this up like 10 minutes before a leopard
what makes them
characteristic
have that characteristic is because they
have these uh scales all over their body
even even their uh proboscis and that's
what makes them uh have their colors
okay so
so
we are being challenged by my mom we're
gonna have to go in the back and confirm
this answer what butterfly uh this is
like when jeopardy gets it wrong and
then
they gotta go back uh
what butterfly family do the monarchs
belong to
we have here nymphalade
yeah uh
it's it's it's nymphalade unfortunately
mom
on this case you are not correct
what what what
what was it that you said absolutely
emily emily would like to put something
forward um
that is the that is the order not the
family of uh
murder yes yeah which falls families
fall in the orders so she has the order
correct
okay so that's interesting
can we get the can we get the
evolutionary chart up there so i can see
well you see it it's broken down into a
uh
you know kingdom phylum class order this
is what your mom said and then the
family oh we were asking
was this so
but what is the lipo daedra like how
general of a family is this
uh
is an order of insects includes
butterflies and mobs okay so that's a
pretty actually pretty good answer
i mean it's [ __ ] she clearly had
something she actually i think my mom is
raising an interesting point here
and emily you came through actually
oh my god you guys i think i'm gonna
have to give this to her
wow
all right
wow wow wow let me change it from
we went back and consulted with the
judges and we just we decided to accept
the answer
[Applause]
damn you've only missed one mom how are
you feeling
good
even even after
uh ruining that guy's life what this is
that part would you know i don't want to
talk about it yeah yeah okay good good
just checking last time great
yeah yeah i'm good
it never happened it did right let's all
just
collective consciousness it's gone
moving on
okay moving on
typically
how many eggs
does a female monarch butterfly lay
over the course of a lifetime
well it depends if she's
if she's um
in her own native you know out there in
the world or if they raise them because
uh
in nature the female butterfly will lay
from 200 to 500 eggs but but if they're
captive you know if they raise them they
can actually lay as much as a thousand
eggs so my guess i'm going to say 200 to
500 because that's natural
i gotta say
i looked over to the judges we're gonna
accept that mom your knowledge of
butterflies
is honestly impressive
staggering
aw inspiring
really it is
what are we up to on the cash prize uh
so it's seven to one so seven that'd be
uh 170
how you guys 75
that's a lot of pizza pies what do we
think
you guys want to give any encouragement
encouraging words to
to my mom there
you're doing great uh
keep going but i'll love you no matter
what
she says she loves oh she's it's the
same
that's so crazy it froze on the same
exact
how is that possible it's like exactly
the same as the last time
what are the chances by the way
her internet is perfectly fine
but i don't know so she does it every
time can figure out a way yeah that in
this day and age of 5g
super fast internet can she find a way
for her phone to work this bad i mean in
los angeles the new phone too right
brand new iphone brand new iphone all
right yeah well
5g
oh
and she dropped that again that's that's
5g and and they're they have great
coverage by the way fantastic coverage
yeah
so good neighborhood for
for cell reception um last time
she
dropped out like this it just like
randomly reconnected so um
hopefully that will happen again
in the meantime um
i mean if she doesn't come back should
we ask them
emily seems to know emily seems to know
a thing or two about monarchs is that
right emily are you pretty slick with
this stuff
a little bit
maybe we should throw into emily at
least until donna gets back well i think
number nine we should say for donna
number nine because that's a hard one
sort of yes right that one's kind of a
trick question
oh
[Music]
that's interesting but if she's
listening you guys gave it away she is
she knows she is my dad has it on the tv
but she's frantically on her phone right
now trying to reconnect yeah they're
probably arguing yeah just like super
angry at each other
all right let me throw one to you emily
okay
hit her with the music here we go here
we go emily stepping in for donna
the butterfly princess uh if you will
right
how long do monarch butterflies
typically live
30 seconds on the hook
the typical lifespan of a monarch
butterfly is what
google here real quick yeah she's
reaching out towards some kind of screen
there
the clock is running 14 days
um
well i think so it's close i'm not sure
what we have here is two to six weeks so
you were
close on the bottom end there
i mean
that's 14 days is two weeks so she
technically she got
in the range
[Music]
i kind of wanna know if my mom knows it
that i mean tech i guess you're right
there i think i'm gonna give it to you
it's 14 pages
i mean you're right there two to six
weeks you got it you really nailed it
there
incredible
all right so we'll count that
as a w i mean yeah
i'm gonna give it to you guys yeah on
page 14.
clearly you've read the 14 pages on
monash
i just messaged your mom asked are you
coming back so um
i know exactly what they're yelling at
each other
gary help me
donna i don't know what's wrong with
your phone
and in the role of a lifetime
gary
gary
[Laughter]
all right emily
here's a one here's one for you okay
okay how many n stars
does a monarch butterfly go through
five
well you're absolutely right that is 100
correct i actually knew that i don't
even know what is it in star
uh it's the
type of metamorphosis how many times
they change how the hell would you know
that
[Music]
you know that monarch princess man are
you also as as invested in monarchs as
as my mom is that a hobby of yours
um i'm a horticulturalist so when i went
to school bugs were kind of a part of
that so i just learned it in school wow
yeah we're classically trained wow
moss too
yes
you know about mosses yeah mostly mods
wow wow wow wow
uh your dad just messaged me said having
problems with internet connection
exactly as i said they have perfect
coverage 5g
fast wi-fi
there's absolutely no
plausible reason why they should have
internet connection issues
they live in an open urban area
with a fantastic coverage smash that
like button
there's there is never any reason for
this to happen but there we go we don't
need her we have the butterfly princess
this is the last question
[Applause]
well there's one more we were saving for
her but i mean if they can't figure it
out i guess
[Music]
gary
i love that pressure's on okay the last
one
what is the traditional significance
of the monarch butterfly arriving in
mexico
during their migration each fall
this is very interesting
traditional significance
cultural significance maybe okay
of arriving in mexico
i don't know that one
well there's no shame in admitting that
you don't know it and the answer is
actually quite interesting
it's part of the ceremony of the um of
the uh
uh
day of the day of the dead they arrive
on day of the dead and the mexicans
regard it as
returning spirits of loved ones isn't
that beautiful that's special
that's special
is that a nice little special thing
that's beautiful love that
all right well we have one we're saving
for my mom should i just save it for her
maybe she'll reconnect
she will eventually right i mean at some
point she'll probably someone saved me
all right what's the what's the final
tally for the final tally here is nine
to two oh correct two incorrect that's
225
dollars my goodness
wow
congratulations guys that is huge
uh oh my mom's calling me
maybe
hey mom
you
know you
i don't know i think sometimes when we
both have our devices on something
screws up
in the house is that uh
i'm not gonna say it's completely
impossible okay
well we proceeded um we proceeded
without you they cleaned up they got 225
dollars
oh great
great did you ask them the question to
answer it yeah emily we dubbed her the
the
butterfly princess in fact because she
knows a lot actually here let me talk
about the question yeah let me toss it
to you and see if you know them
so let's see you guys get a chance to
play for this one um mom
how much food does the average monarch
butterfly eat
while overwintering in central mexico
well that's kind of a trick question
because they don't need anything because
they're on
[Applause]
[Music]
this is this is unbelievable well that
puts the prize up to 250 guys
and that's the final tally that's all of
them thanks mom
it lost me a bunch of money
good
good i'm glad to win it for them well
let me ask you the ones that they got
right let's see i'll just i'll hit you
with them real fast how long do monarch
butterflies typically live
they live six to eight weeks or excuse
me four to six four to six weeks that's
okay basically right on there
how many
how many in-stars does a monarch
butterfly go through
five
look at that and finally
what is the cultural significance of
monarch butterflies arriving in mexico
during the fall
well they kind of look at them as you
know very special like it's their
ancestors coming back did you see this
on the tv
no i didn't see it on a tv i mean i read
about this unbelievable
well we lived in mexico you know even
for six years i'm just shocked i'm
really staggered by your your knowledge
of the butterfly the butterfly life and
kingdom the life and times of the
butterflies
wait a minute wait a minute
the one about
uh the cultural significance that was
one of the two that was incorrect but
donna just got it should we bump that up
into it
now it's 275. so wait how many did they
get wrong just one that would mean just
one wrong one for your
for your fans wait there's 12 questions
yeah so so what are they at now
right now it's ten to two but i'm
suggesting because she added
all right so that's eleven to one
there's only one oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well it's at 275 now thanks mom
no we're very happy for we're very happy
what did you want to ask them on before
we uh say goodbye
well do you know how much um
butterflies will eat
in uh in their lifetime
is that a question for emily i'm
assuming
another trick question
no no no it's not true okay how much of
their body weight did they eat
from the time they're born to the time
they die
oh i have no idea well actually i guess
it's caterpillar
yeah because
you know they don't they don't eat when
they're in uh the butterfly state
all right what's the answer mom hit us
with that
they eat two thousand times their weight
from one thousand maybe you just hit me
with two hundred did you forget a zero
no no no they eat 170 they eat 175 to
200 leaves but they don't they they
they gain like 2 000 times what their
birth weight was we're doubting that
we're actually so so the one that you
propositioned we have doubts about mom
monarch caterpillars
have super-sized appetites eating 200
times their weight in milkweed leaves is
what we're seeing on butterflyranch.com
during its two-week times of life each
caterpillar can eat two thousand times
its birth weight milkweed
that's a fact we're unable to
corroborate
and they eat 175 to 200 leaves per
can you corroborate the 2000 there uh
you're we're getting false information
here we got to make sure
we don't i don't put anything out there
i'm a little hesitant to doubt donna
because she's proven herself to be so uh
such a strong contender here in the
monarch
true that's true however
all of the google results are saying 200
so i don't
i don't know
look it might be better look into it and
we'll talk about it later but thank you
mom
what a wonderful experiment what a
wonderful game show god bless the
butterflies and uh thank you to our good
friends there these lovely fans emily
and um nick nick beautiful beautiful
emily the butterfly princess what a
heartwarming
game
and uh guys send your i don't know do
you guys have zell do you do that
i i don't know what that is all right
we'll talk you'll you'll get talking
message me nick yeah we'll get the info
we'll get you guys paid canada's advance
we got free bank transfers
thank you guys congratulations
congratulations 275 what an incredible
win
wow
[Applause]
all right thank you guys and mom thank
you
i love you all right i love you too
thank you
and uh wow
we'll see you this weekend to celebrate
your belated birthday
let me ask you this
yes since you're so smart about
butterflies
uh-oh
yes answer this question
what do i like in my eggs
what do you like in your eggs what does
your son ethan like in his eggs
cheese
[Music]
that's correct but you that was way too
close
all right thank you mom i'll see you
i'll see you on the weekend all right
you take care okay
bye-bye bye everybody
what a journey and in the wow of a
lifetime
i'm seeing donna's right it's 200 times
leaves which is over 20 uh 2 000 in
their body weight
so why are they writing 200 their body
weight in the head
it was very hard to find that those are
fake ass butterfly fans
[Music]
you're right we shouldn't have doubted
her expertise yeah
i wasn't really confident enough it
seemed like a lot of her answers were
like that they weren't just like the
google search results that's the real
[ __ ] yeah the real [ __ ] you gotta read a
book i gotta say i'm i'm super impressed
i didn't expect her
man to crush that hard
[Applause]
yeah my mom doesn't know anything about
her kids but she knows everything about
monarchs
my mom gave me
for my birthday
she buys every gift for everybody for
any occasion
bath bombs from lush
everything like that
she does it every time i mean i it's
fine you just have like a whole
stockpile yeah
so she comes in and she's like guess
what i got you for your birthday and
then theodore goes because he went with
her
bath bombs from lush and i thought he
was kidding because it's like a joke
that she does and she goes ah
i can't believe you spoiled it and sure
enough she got my ass bath bombs from
lush for my birthday she says don't you
love baths and she asked me that every
year i say i'd never take baths
i'm a grown-ass man who takes baths
i do
you breathe how frequently do you listen
since we moved into this apartment out
here i haven't had a bath since i was a
kid and i'm [ __ ] loving it how much
how often do you take a bath um
just as much as i shower are you [ __ ]
serious i [ __ ] love it i'm like it's
three times a week yeah holy [ __ ] i just
just chilling out there i'm backing up
baby
that's my boy
every time i'm at a hotel room with a
bathtub i hit that [ __ ] dude wait looks
like you were giving me [ __ ] for taking
baths when we lived together oh
i was talking about there too but
you were you were making fun of me for
taking baths
revelation
cameron how often do you take a bath um
when i lived with him the bath was way
better but now it's like once a week or
so
but when i lived with love it was like
my problem with the bath is one
it just takes too long the whole process
of it it's a long process and second of
all
you can't really wash that good in the
bath can you
i'm clean
like how do you wash your ass in the
bath you stand up but you stand up you
shower afterwards too right oh hell no
no that's just a waste of water at that
point but you need to like kind of wash
off at least
for me you're taking a shower after the
bath come on what are you you're trying
to you
society is going to crumble at that
level of opulence
i just know like after getting my aspy
and sparring getting in that hot tub was
just
amazing that makes sense it is good for
that yeah
um
i will say though
california
is like okay almost completely out of
water oh here we go right probably not a
good call not a good time
listen it's not
the problems are much bigger than any
one person and i'm not i'm not trying to
be too judgmental but
it would
be really [ __ ] bad if the state
completely runs out of water which is
totally within the realm possibility
this year from what i understand so
maybe chill on the bats just for the
summer so this summer deal i'll take
i'll i'll take less baths
well hold on whatever you can do we all
gotta do our part we gotta we gotta we
gotta listen the governor put out a a
warning ab this might shock you
this came out
what is the right length of time for a
shower god god forbid a bath my goodness
here let me let me control f bath
switch the governor encourages
californians last month to shorten the
shower to five minutes and stop taking
baths which can use up to 2.5
times as much water
the thought of me getting canceled for
taking a bath is the funniest [ __ ]
the governor said listen
no more baths yeah
i blame you i've been reading a lot
about the water shortage in the last
week or so and so it's like kind of
fresh on my mind and so hearing i blame
you guys four baths a week because dad
also i don't i'm not from here i don't
know this [ __ ] you guys got to talk with
dwp you can only water your lawn a
certain day
if you do that
it's getting pretty serious it's not you
can only water twice a week now
something like that yeah all right i'll
commit to west bath you see the whole
thing about lake mead you know
in uh like the hoover dam
yeah they're running out of water it's
like straight up just not going to be
running in the near future here which is
crazy because it's like 20
of the electricity in california i think
i read
uh i don't know about california as a
whole or if it was just la but
yeah it's it's a big chunk you know i
was up at um
silver
head or arrowhead lake that [ __ ] was
full
oh really yeah but it snowed a lot and
bigger but yeah it was full it looked
beautiful i used to um
we used to go there when i was little
and they used to do fireworks every
fourth of july and there were the last
few times we went there they couldn't do
the fireworks anymore because the lake
was so low they'd do a laser light show
but i'm glad to hear that it's uh it's
up now it's up again you're talking
about lake arrowhead yeah yeah yeah and
it was full it looked great
but that's
uh not the case so
um guys i don't want to have to knock on
you to the city appreciate that but um
water patrol will do what i need
i understand
no more baths
deal yeah people
talking about the almond thing in the
chat yeah that is definitely a pretty uh
it's crazy almonds are like super well
they're not actually they're pretty
expensive almonds yeah almonds are
fairly expensive
and yeah they take an enormous amount of
water so growing them in uh a desert
almonds is not that big of a deal like
we'll be fine with it we could live
without home yeah
especially just for a minute like so we
could take care of this drought stuff
right mm-hmm well it's not like they
only grow in california too it's just
you know i know a lot of vast majority
of them do it currently yeah grow
almonds somewhere else where they have
water for [ __ ] sake
if you drive up from la to like san
francisco there's like miles and miles
and miles of almond trees
eighty percent of the world's supply of
almonds comes from california holy [ __ ]
that's a huge industry yeah that's an
almond paradise that we're living in but
at what cost my friends at what cost and
what cost
people saying almonds are mid anyways i
don't really agree i think almonds are
actually pretty good i like almonds but
i still live without it almonds are good
i like almond milk
yeah but again we're taught we're
dealing yeah those smokers they're not
they're the best nut the delicacy nut
they're by far the best that's cashew
that's the dose
absolutely almond is is s t or not we
do you remember this it was a long time
ago so my favorite nuts i'm just gonna
put this out there s tier for me
almond pistachio oh yeah
and then b and then you go to a tier and
you're going like uh
pecan and cashew
and that's basic those are the only nuts
that matter everything else is both no
you know what's estier for me
tell them love these knots
[Laughter]
my mind thank you
mom
let's go very good i guess we never did
i'm looking through our old like maybe
we maybe it was
part of the discussion at one point
that's from your tick tock bro
oh that's funny well there you go i just
laid it out does anyone disagree with my
ranking
i think walnuts are the best oh walnut i
love walnuts they're like juicy i don't
know how to describe it i hate that [ __ ]
i don't know they like pop
exactly
if we can't bath you guys can't eat
almond nuts
if we can't bath you can't nuts
okay i'll swear off nuts
i did not come on my dog i did not come
on my nuts
somebody donated five dollars and said
y'all
live right along the pacific i've never
understood the water shortage
[ __ ] can you drink the ocean
do you know anybody that drinks the
ocean
just remove the salt bro
you ever heard water water everywhere
not a drop to drink you [ __ ] can't
drink the ocean dude
i've been chugging the water
the [ __ ]
but we are i think we do need to work on
some desalination and stuff like that
but yeah i think just doing it at scale
is still extremely expensive but we
might not uh have a choice hey shut up
members go up drop 20 subbies yo
20. one of our great patrons
members go up oh he did 20 before that
too are they
dedicated account members go up indeed
butterfly icon today for the don arks
dude the ocean's right there like just
drink that just drink the ocean bro
i wish it was that easy i really do but
there's like
billions of years of fish [ __ ] in it
which basically makes it undrinkable
let's be honest
just wait really
well what do you think's floating around
in there
birch
fishes take shits
the puffer fish
turns into a circle
but isn't there fish in pretty much all
water
yo i was right blizzard woofie or mod
coming through
we did a [ __ ] oh we did it
macadamia got asked here i disagree with
that everything this is your tier list
what do you mean no that would you guys
influence my my
that must have been one of your guys's
influence that's [ __ ]
i mean i walnut got f-tier sam
whoa
well i'm not straight i like walnuts i'm
with you when the [ __ ] did we do this
wait acorn can you even literally the
first episode of after dark after dark
number one
wow
we came hard
yeah we came out with a bang open not
tearless raw heavy as hell why would
walnuts be f
i don't i personally i think that's the
worst nut they're super hard to open and
it's just not that no like already
opened walnuts
um
wait what it's just about the flavor not
the not the experience we didn't we
didn't deduct pistachio because it's
worth it you know what i mean
it was all about the flavor wait did it
get effort remember somebody else gave
another 40. i think i think someone else
made it and you all read off of it
oh
oh i think you're right this might not
have been our maybe we were just
discussing the placement here because
this makes no sense
i i can't raid acorn yeah what the [ __ ]
are you a squirrel right
thank you squirrels without acorns then
like we lose uh squirrels oh it was a
call-in too okay
it's coming back to me now somebody
called in was like i have a nut ranking
i want you guys to judge it okay so
well moving on thank you enough about
the nuts yes enough i have the great
luxury of coming
okay was that vinnie yeah
let's see what else we got here um
this is
let's see johnny depp is about to get
300 million for
oh i guess let's do this let's share our
stories um
that is the title of the episode it's
true
so the story the question for all of you
guys today is
what is the worst thing you've done as a
kid
[Music]
and you know kids really get into some
weird [ __ ] so
the worst thing you've done as a kid
would you even admit to it here today
thank you members go up you are a
you're a generous person
um let's i'll start i guess
sure what you got so as a kid
you know it was hard for me to pull
anecdotes
i know he got into lots of trouble
generally speaking like i used to get in
fights and stuff when i was a young kid
just scrapping damn dude you're hooking
it up thank you members go up
[Music]
yeah
doing stupid stuff like going into the
bathroom and setting off fireworks i did
that a couple of times or definitely
[ __ ] in the urinal no i'm just
kidding i never did that i didn't do
that one either but people at my school
did do that let it be known you ever
walk into a bathroom and somebody's [ __ ]
in the urinal and it's like whoa what
are the logistics he got expelled for
doing that in my school wait
yeah i've definitely walked into the
public bathroom wait you got expelled
for [ __ ] no no a kid that somebody
did oh yeah dude chill dude
members go up and giving 120.
dude that's a lot of though thank you
that's a lot of pizza pie who is this
gracious butterfly god
they even have the butterfly they have a
butterfly icon
that's so cool i love that
oh by the way speaking of members we got
to do the um
the tiptoe watch soon
okay
hell yeah i don't know this weekend or
not
we should get it on the calendar okay
obviously no pressure for you guys to
attend so i'll be attending i want to
watch this i'll pay i'm going to pay
i'll pay you guys for a regular day and
next month even nicer yeah well you know
it's next weekend
thank you yeah do you know what next
yeah
yeah are you going
me yeah we were kind of assuming you
weren't but no okay i think it's the way
you got excited there no i'm just sick i
want i i mean i prefer you guys just go
do on okay yeah that's on the scene
reporting that's the plan
that i'm so excited holy smokerino i am
so excited i am so excited
guys
maybe in two weeks we'll do it
but you guys don't have to come
obviously i'll pay you for the day and
no i'm there i'm not missing
yeah we had years of hype on this [ __ ]
so let's try to do that in two weeks
then okay
exciting
so anyway as i was saying yeah i did all
kinds of stupid [ __ ] you know
i would get into my parents like
or not my parents my dad specifically
porn stash
i've talked about this on the show this
man is a pervert my dad is [ __ ]
sick he had hundreds of bootleg vhs's
hundreds
in his closet
and like hardcore gnarly [ __ ] bro pretty
sure it [ __ ] me up for life seeing
that
like i'm talking about like a hard core
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that i was watching at
like eight years old
meanwhile your mom's watching
butterflies in the other room
so gnarly
yeah so we would pop those in and invite
like all the neighborhood kids over
i'm pretty sure i ruined it
when you were eight you were doing this
yes i'm saying it really damaged me
right one time i told my therapist about
that he says wow
he goes wow we'll have to dig into that
later
just back just off he's like wow that
would really [ __ ] you up seeing that
eight is like very little yes
you're sure on the age yes okay wow yeah
because my brother's two and a half
years so he gets into [ __ ] right a
little bit sooner than me and i'm just
tagging along
i'm talking about like
the work i mean the most hardcore gnarly
[ __ ] you can imagine
the chat's asking would you even imagine
some really gnarly [ __ ] well just like
just like
[ __ ] gangbangs and anal and crazy
[ __ ] like that i mean
hardcore porn okay it wasn't like
vanilla [ __ ] is what i mean i understand
i understand chad was asking what you
meant by inviting people over like i
don't know if you guys understand that's
a big deal as a kid like that's power oh
yeah that's like that's a huge well you
just mention it in passing right yeah
and then everybody wants to come over
your house and my parents were gone all
day at work so yeah it worked out so you
were aware of what you were watching oh
yeah
i think too in that era i i
i have to imagine the dynamic is very
different nowadays with internet porn
being what it is because when we were
kids well i'm sure there was internet
porn but the internet wasn't nearly as
ubiquitous this was before the internet
and yeah like you know people had porn
on like he said vhs tapes and [ __ ]
because my dad was like a rare commodity
i when that when the we first got the
internet this was app we'd already been
watching that [ __ ] for years but we went
to like boobs.com me and my brother we
closed the door.com we went to like
boobs.com and it was like
you know that's so funny it wasn't that
good compared to the stuff we've already
seen i see yeah but before the internet
we would like we'd be like yo we heard
there's some nudie magazines at by the
by the
in the uh like lake side or the yeah
about in the forest that's the yeah in
the forest so we would go there and
there were there were sometimes that was
the craziest thing like people knew
about these
but yeah you're right i mean kids these
days grow up with the internet you have
access to some gnarly [ __ ] so
maybe it's normal now to just grow up
seeing watching people get anally
gangbanged
it's pretty dramatic for me genital
region was exposed i cannot i like
i see you but a lot smaller watches i
was a beautiful innocent young boy
in your little birkenstocks and tiny
shorts innocence lost
dude members go up is still dropping
members remember members go up you gotta
maybe just chill
that's 220. 220 are you a saudi prince
what's happening i mean how
i'm like five dollars i mean that's the
[ __ ] what
like isn't each gifted membership five
bucks yes it's a lot of [ __ ] money i
know i know it's amazing thank you well
it's nice because she's sharing the love
with all the food troopers
it's very nice we're gonna have a big
beautiful watch party in two weeks over
a thousand dollars
yeah it's awesome thank you bro god damn
yeah one time i i had a bunch of friends
over and we were watching some [ __ ]
and we thought we heard the garage door
open and dude you panicked like crazy
like
you tried to get everything back one of
my friends bolted in the backyard jumped
the [ __ ] fence and we're little kids
that's the biggest fence it's like an
episode of cops like he's on the run
right jumps the fence and we never saw
him
again the rest of the day into someone
else's yard you know what i mean yeah
like straight up what you gonna do and
then um
nobody was there right but
that was the best part
but he was so scared
but
so the worst thing i can think of though
that that's all kind of just floating
around
the dumbest worst thing i've done
is
so near our house there's a massive park
open green
grass
and there is a
is a um
elementary school which we attended
and it was summer and there's a summer
day camp there
which we attended and but we weren't
there on this day for some reason
and it's a huge massive green field and
they have um
remember when they started doing they
put like trailers out there
it was like makeshift classrooms they
would put like trailers and mods
mods oh
the modulars we call them bungalows at
our uh school but yes yeah they're just
straight up trailers dude
bungalows yeah
but you guys know what i mean yep so
there's a bunch of them
so we're at the back of this massive
field
and down all the way at the end
are these giant ma uh
you know trailers
and inside there's a bunch of kids kids
we knew
and my buddy
just got a balloon a water balloon
launcher
and i don't know if you guys have seen
these but these are gnarly man these are
basically surface-to-air missiles i mean
these things
have an incredible capacity
check it out here
yeah something like this you know
exactly
and you need like two dudes to hold the
side and one person will launch it and
for some reason we thought you know this
would be a good idea to just start
launching balloons
at this portable classroom
and i i i'm serious it must have been
like
longer than a foot or maybe a footballs
field so these are little [ __ ]
torpedoes coming down
deadly airstrikes
and so we're launching them we're
launching them
they start yelling at us like stop doing
that [ __ ]
and we gear up for one more and it was i
pulled it back my homies are there you
know
i pulled it back all the way
all the [ __ ] way
right
it starts going towards the the trailer
and it hits one of the windows dead
[ __ ] center
it was dead
dead center
and a massive boom just shook that
neighborhood
reverberated through that [ __ ]
neighborhood
we just we basically booked it to our
friend's house we ran for life and the
[ __ ] up part is they knew it was us
because they saw us from the beginning
and not only that they knew who we were
we go there we literally went to that
daycare or summer camp or whatever
[Music]
and one of our friends was sitting next
to the window there inside
and he saw his life flash before his
eyes
did you get caught
yes so so
here's what happened we ran back to our
friend's house
and he had like a tree house in the back
and we were up there just hiding and
praying like
please god just please god don't let us
get caught and then his mom comes out
and she's like yo there's the police are
in front they want to talk to you guys
and then we're like oh my god bro oh my
god
i thought we were dead i thought we were
done and dead and cooked
but she was just [ __ ] with us
and we were so scared
yeah but we went to we the window didn't
break by the way
wait no it was a miracle of god
it hit it right dead in the [ __ ]
center boom dude
but if it broke i think we would have
killed our friend it was sitting there
genuinely
yo you're in trouble
can you imagine that poor guy was just
sitting there under the window
uh and we got so lucky he didn't break
because i think he would have got
seriously injured
and we would have been in big trouble
yeah but we went to um
we went back to summer camp and we
caught [ __ ] for it but
yeah they thought we were psychos dude
just sitting there launching bombs at a
bunch of kids
but there you have it maybe it's not
that bad i don't know just couldn't
really think of anything specific that's
pretty bad
yeah it was pretty bad but you know with
one of those things my parents never
found out about it
and i that was one of those things that
i just kind of got away with
[Music]
my mom would have [ __ ] killed me
if she found out i was doing that
so there you have it guys
thank you
there it is by the way uh members go up
seems to have rounded out the membership
drive
the solo membership drive that they were
running at 275 i'm inferring
that that was a
gifted member for every dollar that whoa
members go up emily yes
or maybe it's a coincidence but i feel
like that's gotta be yeah someone said
did you get spanked ethan yeah my dad
used to spank me
i scared the i it scared the [ __ ] out i
was scared of my dad he wasn't that
violent or anything but
oh he's the kind of guy who would come
home and then everyone's like [ __ ] dad's
home and then you have to like go in a
different room and just it's not like
fun like yeah dad's home it's like [ __ ]
but no it's it was it wasn't that bad he
would just hit my butt
but looking back that's just kind of
more traumatic than
like getting hit by your
by your dad even in a way like that
which was totally normal at the time
is really
is really um
traumatic i just it really
i thought it was so scary i was so
scared of it and i from what i
understand all the studies have said
that like spanking your kids is
completely
not helpful
in discipline my dad spanked my ass into
shape but i mean
i'm kind of thankful he did a certain
point in my life but i would never do it
to my kids i don't think
i hope not
well there was a certain point where i
was so scared of my dad
spaking me i did something [ __ ] up i
don't remember what it was
and i was like i'm not coming home cause
dad's gonna [ __ ]
spank the [ __ ] out of me
and then my mom made him promise that he
wouldn't he wouldn't do it so i came
home and that was the last time he
spanked me maybe he didn't realize it
was so traumatic for me i don't know
is it legal in america right now yeah to
spank your kids yeah
it's [ __ ] up i mean not to punch him
in the face or something crazy but
spanking is like pretty normal
anything like that is illegal in sweden
you can't spank your child
[ __ ] no
it's not that serious it's a little
[ __ ] i mean i think it's pretty bad
now
think about how traumatizing you just
said it was for you but it's not like
bad enough that like they should go to
jail or get their [ __ ] kids taken
away or something you can't i don't know
that's probably
like different from where wherever you
come from yeah i think i think it's
really [ __ ] up i think in today's like
if my husband spanked my kid in like
this world that we're living in now i
would be like what the [ __ ] absolutely
not
like i would be i would be taken aback
listen i will never hurt
my child in any way physically like
you know
i want my kids to be happy when i come
home and excited to see me that being
said
i don't know that you need the police
involved because you hit your kid on the
butt
[Music]
gotta help me if i call the police and
my parents
i better be ready to leave that house
and never come back
people are saying it's abuse guys i'm
not it's just it's you're just hitting
them on the but first of all i it's
[ __ ] up
but you're gonna get the police involved
for hitting on the butt that's gonna
make everything worse
the trauma will be worse
it will be worse on your parents
it's horrible it's going to be a
horrible
outcome so all the countries in red have
outlawed
spanking your kids
that's really surprising pretty
you know kind of diverse selection of uh
countries i would say europe is not down
with spanking the kids but england see
that's probably why i'm against it
england is but it's illegal in scotland
and
uh ireland um yeah all of the nordic
countries have it outlawed germany has
it listen i think really it's illegal
it's illegal though it's [ __ ] up and
it's wrong and people shouldn't do it i
don't think the police need to get
involved
obviously there's a point where the
police do need to get involved but if
we're just talking about spanking as we
know it a little discipline hit on the
butt
you really want the police coming for
that yeah
come on the police make every [ __ ]
situation worse
like i'm thinking like if the police
came and charged my dad
like no that would have been so much
worse for me my life for him i mean
you know look
there's a there's a way that you speak
okay
you just you hit him on the butt that's
it a couple times and then they go it's
nothing anything more than that like i
had a neighbor dude
he used to pull out a [ __ ] belt and
while i was there that scared the [ __ ]
out of me my dad never did that
he was like
i was like what the [ __ ] scared the [ __ ]
out of me oh i used to get the belt
really oh yeah from my grandparents
never my parents
but yeah the belt was bad the belt is
scary
and no weapons no weapons that's not
fair yeah once you endure just weapons
then i think we got a problem
arabs usually like the the slippers
professional
slippers listen people are saying it's
totally abused call the cops stop you
can't be serious these
i agree they don't saying call the cops
are the same people that say hey cap in
our chat every day guarantee you
i'm serious uh
listen i was never i think it's [ __ ]
up i don't think people should spank
your kids but i totally understand what
you're saying involving the police like
calling the police when your dad spanked
you for you know coming home later
but that doesn't mean it shouldn't be
illegal because it being illegal
prevents most people from doing it right
because if like
it's better than having it i think it
probably should be illegal i kind of
agree yeah so
it's pretty barbaric and the goal is to
not have anyone be arrested and people
just abide by the law right so
i don't know it's interesting i didn't
even think about it being illegal
well child abuse is illegal obviously so
right but corporal punishment is how
they that's that's what it's referred to
um as
to separate it from
you know actual abuse
um but yeah i mean i think a lot of uh
research probably shows it has a similar
effect of
abusing your kid physically and so
why is one okay and the other isn't you
know what i mean it's
plus like i said i mean from everything
i've heard it's not a very effective
discipline
uh
way to discipline your kids anyways so
it's just kind of a lose-lose-lose like
why not just but how many of us were
actually hit as kids in some way like
the majority of us and i wasn't
okay yeah yeah your parents seemed
progressive abe was i was sam was
i was cam was you see it was [ __ ]
normal when we grew up just [ __ ] up
and crazy and imagine how bad our
parents got it their parents just beat
the [ __ ] out of them and nobody gave a
[ __ ] for sure
you know what i mean
so progress is going in the right
direction but holy [ __ ] man
my grandfather used to tell
my dad and his siblings to go pick a
stick
if the stick breaks you're gonna pick a
bigger one
that whole now that's why i got it
that's really funny i know in a uh quite
a few states in the united states
corporal punishment in school
is still legal
now if someone else is hitting your then
then we're dealing with crime and no no
one touching anybody's kid yeah no
there's still a lot of states where
that's [ __ ] crazy to me punishment my
cousin tim
and i think that explained some things
used to what the school used to
discipline him dude that is his mom with
encouragement yeah
the mom would be like beat the [ __ ] out
of my son
just really discipline him
check this out [ __ ] wild
the red all those red states uh yeah
baby those are the yeehaw states
my classroom had a paddle it was
literally like straight up are you
kidding yeah yeah i thought that was
like just a elementary school thing yeah
no never in my life did i have i seen a
teacher hit a student
but but so what kind of stuff would you
do wrong that would result in a beating
it would be stuff like talking oh just
minor yeah it was like that was like the
punishment well
that's crazy
[Music]
well
bro italian and latine families the
wooden spoon is what they would pull out
the wooden spoon
my dad uh he tells a story about once it
literally broke
oh my god isn't that crazy how hard it
stinks well they it used the same spoon
for like a very long time supposedly but
crazy crazy story yeah that that is
really i think it's really sad i gotta
make it clear i think it's all really
sad you know
just saying
i'm kind of shocked that people that the
police can come for spanking
[Music]
if you called the if like a kid called
the police here was like yo my dad just
spanked me they'd be like your dad's
gonna wind up dead
they're gonna kill your dad and your dog
and then you're gonna get raped in
prison
your dog is gonna probably wind up dead
kill the dog kill your brother kill your
mom you only put an orphan
yeah [ __ ] the police call them
call them for
the least [ __ ] possible am i the new
phillyd thumb now
is there a reason you're asking that out
of the blue i see the chat blowing up oh
the chat says i wonder what he got me
for yeah
he got you
you i guess it's worth mentioning too
like swedish police isn't american
police either right they don't show up
and kill your dog
i'm not seeing you on philly
maybe on twitter did he well sometimes
it takes are you actually seeing today's
episode because on the channel page it
takes a while to show up i went to both
i see the latest three days ago but let
me see twitter
yeah you probably posted one on twitter
or something dudes guys i'm not saying
uh spanking should be allowed i'm just
saying what the [ __ ]
just saying what do you want me to say i
don't think the police should break up a
family because he spanked his kid that's
[ __ ] insane yeah
oh we got it
how do you get me
oh yeah i'm in the thumbnail guys i lied
guess who lied again
pretty low-res photo of you i guess i'm
legit not even seeing it on his twitter
or his youtube it must have just been
published yeah it takes a second
yeah let's see the thumbnail
oh yeah see it's not even showing up yet
somebody uh just said in the chat uh in
a super chat
that they get the ruler for being
left-handed
lefty you damn lefty i'm a lefty
i almost got that for being a lefty but
you get beat up for being left-handed
yeah it's was it
were you in catholic school yeah it's
uber catholic okay i was going to say i
believe catholic school that's kind of a
thing is it a sin to be left-handed yeah
kim did you go to school in 1870 by chad
i mean
well no i i got saved from it my my mom
prevented it from happening but okay
well that's good so what's the theory
they beat the left-handed out of you
yeah yeah
simple hand
so so so you still left-handed or did
you convert well i never got beat so but
i mean
to bring it on topic i guess like to i
got hit as a kid a little bit and uh i
was a bad kid so it didn't work
a few stories if you guys are interested
check it out guys me and taylor swift
you lied
now what did he let's see what what did
he get me on
he's probably talking about the
thumbnail uh cake that we made on friday
he's probably just mentioning it
he lied
oh no i gotta know i gotta see i'm i'm
listening to it yeah he got you can't
you want to go next
sure all right let's see what you got
kim i was
a bad kid um
we used to i mean i don't really have
too many specifics but actually i
thought of one yesterday i was talking
to ian about
um
we used to do devil's night a lot for
halloween and we smash pumpkins and [ __ ]
i never tp to anyone but uh one i
thought of yesterday was
we used to hate mr people a lot do you
know what that is
um in high school we were like you know
hey mister can you buy us booze can you
buy this oh sh like
yeah um
so we used to do that a lot but then one
that
tied it into my adult hit is somebody
hey mistered us in college um but for
cigarettes
um but instead of buying them smokes we
took the money and then went out the
other entrance of the guests
i know and then that's pretty good and
then as we were driving by we flipped
off the kid
oh my god
i'm a hero dude i save the kid from
cancer no you are i'm a hero
you are a villain sir well first of all
cam thanks for confessing you that yeah
so wait how old were you when that
happened
oh i was in college at that time oh [ __ ]
bro hey i needed the money too
so what hold on and how old was the kid
uh probably high school like i saw
myself in him for sure and what he gave
you like 20 bucks yeah
was it you and your friends or what how
many people yeah it was me my best
friend
and actually my best friend who i used
to hate mr people with too so
you did not pay it forward my friend
that is and you bailed with the 20 and
then the worst part is the flipping off
[ __ ] you stomping on his face hey it was
pretty i saved him i saved him he
learned an important lesson that day
don't trust kids your age because we
used to hate mr
uh a lot of older people so oh
do you feel bad about that or are you
there you don't you don't give a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] damn
that's awesome cam i'm learning a new
side of you i was a bad kid
but you were in college you weren't that
young yeah this is really a kid's story
you're an adult
but you know i used to
before we were 21 in college we used to
do that for beer and one time some dude
took off for like 50 bucks and it was
just it was so heart-wrenching
surprised that didn't happen to me it
was just it was so sick bro it just
broke our [ __ ] heart like we were so
excited for the night and some guy just
took off with our 50. it was just like
[ __ ]
get [ __ ]
but you know people used to hit me up
for that when i was old enough and i was
like i can't not [ __ ] no i just i can't
do it
i didn't pay it forward because i was
like
i i'm sorry i just
it's too sketchy
i don't want to buy kids alcohol it
really could it's very illegal
it's funny where i live there's like a
service underground service for underage
people to buy alcohol
there's this one number or a snapchat
contact who everyone had back when i
went to school no [ __ ] and we called
them up and they came to deliver [ __ ]
yeah
tiny little red car some giant dude just
comes out super sweaty
in the middle of the night usually and
pops the trunk up of this old ass beaten
like
uh car and there's just like vodka beer
ciders
everything that's what it is
yeah
we have the hook up is that super like
illegal there to do that yeah but it's
like a giant underground illegal network
that says alcohol they buy it in germany
and they drive up to sweden and they
sell it
oh i wonder how young would they is
their kid too young where they're like i
can't sell you you're too young are they
hell no did like a eight-year-old could
buy booze from them
probably maybe they have a limit but who
knows we were probably 14 or something
like that yeah and there's this one like
a truck stop too where all the polex of
polish people like old men that drives
uh trucks
they always bought booths before they
came up here and sold it super expensive
to miners
[Music]
it's crazy
super dodgy too yeah
that's kind of awesome though you get a
delivery service
yeah that's wild
i just got it grew up we heard that he
got arrested and was sitting in jail oh
dude well that's not
i just got another report for my crazy
ed [ __ ] tweet
keep it coming losers
your crazy [ __ ] well drop it down
downtown
let's get ready
[Music]
let's get
let's
well that's a great story cam i gotta
say that really surprised me you know i
i mean damn and the worst part about it
is it it's happened to me as a kid too
where we got our money stolen
the the uh
the cycle continues yeah
but we didn't get flipped off that was
just insult to injury i guess what was
his face like when you flipped him off
driving away
did you catch a face
yeah they were pissed
oh man
devastating
there that's a great story cam
[ __ ]
dan's dan's triggered right now
i'm so upset yeah no
dan what's yours um
well like like cam i i was a little
delinquent quit uh kid um i actually
reached out to some old buddies of mine
i grew up with and was like what was the
worst [ __ ] we ever did
and they they came back with like a
[ __ ] list of things i had totally
forgotten about
um that are like
bad but like aren't necessarily great
stories um just typical
delinquent teenager [ __ ]
um
however there is one story
that i thought
fit pretty well and it is something that
like i'll occasionally think about and
feel pretty guilty about
um
basically
when i was probably like 13 or 14.
um
i had this friend
who
was getting kind of bullied by this
group of girls actually
and the way they were bullying him
there was a few ways but one thing is
back then there was this show in l.a
called love line with dr drew actually
of course you remember remember love
line yeah so
for you was it like me
and people of my age that like everybody
would listen to my sister loved it
she's quite a bit older like 10 years
yeah and so i would listen in with her
right and so it was kind of like a
for people that aren't familiar was like
kind of a
who's an advice show advice show yeah it
was on the radio it was late at night in
l.a it was adam carolla and and uh
dr through yeah um
real quick can i just say something
apparently i said a slur for polish
people i thought that was just how you
said polish people i don't know how to
say what what's a like a sweet sweet
you'd say polish
holy [ __ ] okay so i apparently i said a
bad word i i didn't know my bad yeah i
you know i heard you say that and
something i was like i guess that maybe
i thought maybe you were right the word
of course is
i don't know do is the polish people
really get
it's kind of incredible that you can
have a slur for a whole country is there
anywhere else where that's true
yeah of course
i thought it was just like i guess
you're right like a crowd american
german or something
it was you said pull lock by the way
yeah poles is how you say it apparently
that's offensive so sorry about these
swedish
yeah rather confused i guess i don't
know but it's okay but yeah we we love
you
love and uh
if some people are saying it's not a
slur
i don't know
i think you have to make another apology
though
because you interrupt the dance story it
doesn't know about
the shot well if you were getting
cancelled
yeah
should we play what's a slur for a whole
country
kraut for german
but let's not play that game yeah that
sounds like a boring game can you think
of an other one i can think of a few
that i'm gonna keep can you type it to
me
let's get it
no i'm not gonna even type with you all
i can think of is crowd
oh i can well i could think of another
one
this one's more offensive i won't say it
all right let's continue dan continue
with your story please oh where was i so
yeah um
so yeah love line that's right so
it was very popular with
people of my age and
they kept calling in
pretending to ask for advice about like
their boyfriend who was this guy that
was a friend of mine you know
having erectile dysfunction or like
pooping himself during sex and like all
of this stuff and they would say his
name because they knew everybody was
like listening to it and it was just
like their way of like [ __ ] with him
basically
um and like i said they were doing a lot
of other stuff so anyways i wanted to
help my buddy
get
revenge on this girl
and so what i did
was i
[Music]
convinced one of her friends
to
that i had had a falling out with my
friend and that you know i hated him now
too you know what i mean
and kind of i was a sleeper agent
and basically i convinced this girl
that i knew a way
that she could hack his computer
and she was really stoked on the idea
and she thought that would be so funny
i didn't know anything about hacking
what i did know
was
this is probably still possible but back
in the day
uh like windows 98
you know era there was a dos command
that you could type
that basically
nuked your computer it would just
completely erase your hard drive and
normally would have like lots of
confirmations and stuff but if you added
an additional like command at the end of
it you could skip all of that so
literally you type this in you hit enter
your computer's [ __ ]
right it's just
nuked
so
i told her
she could open up the dos prompt and you
could type this in plus his name plus
his phone number or something to make it
like seem believable
yeah and she uh she bought it and
what i didn't know was that this was her
family computer because this was like
pre-cell phone pre everybody having you
know this was in like probably 2000
2001.
um
and so she did it
and she nuked like her dad's computer
it's horrible
uh that they all shared and um
you know
i don't think
she was ever able to explain it away to
her family because
she knew she was doing it maliciously
right there's no way of explaining that
there's no way of explaining that how
how it came like how did like why did
you do this oh i was trying to hack
somebody's computer and i'm a [ __ ] and
and delete it
so so
i got away with it completely clean
but um
i don't know for some like
years like i thought that was the
funniest [ __ ] that i actually pulled
that off at the time now i think
background is pretty funny it's pretty
funny it's like alt f4 irl delete
system32 i mean a hat you actually did
it yeah and they they were not uh
technical because you you could you know
reinstall windows and get it all back
and running but i heard that they didn't
know what to do and they ended up just
tossing out the comments oh my god
[Laughter]
so so what happened to the girl was she
busted by her family
from what i recall i think they just
played it off like she didn't know what
happened like she was just like oh the
computer doesn't work or whatever um so
i don't think anybody really suffered
any consequences other than her parents
which
again is why
i realize now that that was pretty
[ __ ] up i made it too it's pretty good
i'm not gonna i mean
you pulled it off
and you know i just remembered a story i
don't remember this my sister tells it
that me and my brother were apparently
chasing her around with knives
and she had to lock herself in the
bathroom i don't remember it
but me and my brother were two years
apart and we were crazy and my sister is
10 years older than me
and she said she said we were chasing
her with knives and she had to lock
herself in the bathroom
so that's pretty bad but i don't
remember it
that's pretty scary though can you
imagine
some little [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] with
big ass knives
that is wild
yeah it sounds wild i don't remember it
but that's what she says so i don't know
yeah i'd be like hey there
hey jessica
o.j simpson style hey there hey twitter
world it's me
all right who's next who else has got a
good one
i have a i have a pretty good one
um
all right
so when i was like a child
and growing up i was a pretty good kid
but high school years which at this
point the story was about five six years
ago so i think
that does that count as a child high
school was five years well how old were
you i was like 17 16. yeah i'll take
whatever i mean yeah that's kid yeah
give me what you got i was like a
particular menace in high school at
times um
okay so this story it was before
orientation one year
um it was the night before and i was
like we have to do something like it's
the night before
we have to go back to school this is the
last night of summer let's do something
and i don't condone obviously underage
drinking this story does um
include it however um
so my friends and i we were just like
throwing them back
feeling the last night of summer and we
at this time
um
it was like when jake paul was in the
hype house and the address was very very
i remember like people were showing up
all the time it was around that time
okay and um so we were like oh my god
i kind of want to see it you know so
we were
the friends who were drinking we had a
designated driver
um we went
we
sat outside the house
we got very drunk
and then when i got home
i threw up and my mother had to help me
and i was
so out of it
that i like
had to be she had to undress me she had
to throw me in the shower and she said
that i threw up the entire night and
then she had to drive me to orientation
the next morning
and i think that's the most that i've
ever like apologized to my mom i don't
think it's that bad it was i feel like
that's happened to everybody yeah really
more or less you should have been like
sorry mom i'm jake pauler oh my god it
was a day
i've i haven't really gotten sick
besides that with drinking so maybe it's
because that story but
she i've dealt with worship with gila
being pissed drunk really yeah
she used to get [ __ ] crazy dude
she doesn't anymore it was just one time
where she got like blackout drunk on
this super strong gin
and i thought she was gonna die
don't have to carry her upstairs in new
york i think i've told him
i did not have a story like yeah but i
don't actually don't think it's that bad
i think you're just a good kid
i i would hope so but my mother does
reference that night as being a
nightmare
i can imagine
um
okay
there you have it please stand up i
didn't realize i was such that was yeah
that was that was not too bad all right
olivia i thought these stories had to be
about when we were actually like kids um
so i didn't realize that y'all were
doing [ __ ] up things as adults
well i was a very good kid for the most
part cam's like i stole some kids money
yesterday
so everyone's mad at jeff whitaker for
doing it but when i do it i'm the i'm
the villain too i mean when i don't do
it wait when did jeff whitake steal
someone's money well he
bought the alcohol
allegedly oh oh oh oh oh oh when i do it
you didn't do it
when i when i don't do it saving a kid
from cancer everyone's mad at me
i'm just kidding
[ __ ] the haters bro yeah
go ahead amy no yeah so when i was a kid
anything bad i did was kind of
influenced by my cousins who were the
worst kids ever yeah and they used to
think it was the funniest [ __ ] in the
world that when i went to the bathroom
at a restaurant to come in there and
turn up the lights and then just beat
the living [ __ ] out of me
and uh
i took it for a while but then i started
to join in and uh
it's kind of hard to describe but like
imagine going into a bathroom and
literally trying to kill the other
person in there they would grab the
trash can whatever it was the mirror
kick off the mirror put soap in your eye
it's really [ __ ] up [ __ ] and i think
one day i just let it uh
i was a little afraid of being [ __ ]
with for every reason maybe we were
talking [ __ ] at the table i took a it's
like a fork with me to the bathroom
and i knew this was
a rough decision because if i show the
fork then they're going to get in their
mind that we can use weapons now they
need to bring forks yeah and when i was
a kid i mean i went in the bathroom i
see my cousins coming behind me and my
cousin starts coming at me i pulled a
fork out and i wouldn't say this now but
i was a kid i go stay away from me you
fat [ __ ]
and he
he's like oh you think i'm scared of
that and he for some reason he he said
fat cobra attack
and he ran at me full speed i wasn't
expecting to him i kind of shanked him
in the stomach
he was fine he was fine but uh
that was one thing i felt really bad
about as a kid is i i shanked my
cousin's doing the fact that it sounds
like he had it
he was the aggressor he was aggressor
but you know you shouldn't shake your
cousins
i don't think it's that bad either i
gotta say okay shank your cousin's kids
well you just stabbed him with a nut
with a fork yeah that's pretty bad i
feel like the other thing
in self-defense i guess
muted realizing muted the other day when
we were talking about this about how we
were going to talk about the worst
things we did as kids
you were like i was a really
well-behaved kid i don't have any
stories your story is way [ __ ] you
[ __ ] stab somebody well let's i'm
saying i was in self-defense but he was
fine how bad could it have been he had
like little fork marks in his stomach
i don't know it seems like he had it
coming and he did have it coming yeah i
mean
yeah i was having trouble thinking of
something did it stop him in his tracks
when you got him with the fork or did it
continue
he he continued on me and we almost like
we tilted the stall a little bit we got
banned from using the bathroom at one of
the restaurants that we just always go
to with his dad
we had a reputation around town for
being idiots that's pretty insane was
that your cousin tim that's his brother
brennan oh but yeah it was tim and
brendan who's a bigger uh degenerate tim
or brendan uh
brennan's normal
he's aged out normally yeah me and
brendan like when we started college we
lived together for like five years
normal human being
well i gotta say i don't know but i just
i find the fork story not that bad
sometimes that's just the way it is yeah
i guess so thank you you've relieved me
of my childhood yeah i don't know why
you would feel bad about it you're
defending yourself it's fine yeah
but it's not like you went if you went
up to him yeah unprovoked and stabbed
him with it was like
[ __ ] like that yeah
all right who's got a bad one
we have sam ian
zach zaks must have a good one
i was a pretty well behaved kid
um i started to get more [ __ ] up as i
got older though that was the problem
um
there's one story i can think of um
we used to have this toy chest in our
house and i was probably like five or
six you know
and uh for whatever reason i just
whenever i had to pee
i didn't want to go to the bathroom
so i would just piss all over this toy
chest
and there'd just be urine all over the
toys and [ __ ] like that
[Music]
and i did that for about a year
but i i remember you
you mentioned yeah i was gonna say
zach's told this story but i'm actually
interested to get more details so
how old were you like five or six and
you were like i'm just gonna piss in
this toy chest full of toys i don't know
why yeah and did you play with the toys
yeah i did and did they stink
i don't recall i would assume i'm
surprised your mom never like smelled
that i'm sure they did i got caught but
i i don't remember
how
i got caught i mean i would assume the
smell but
yeah i used to just [ __ ] piss and
that's interesting and why'd you stop
i think i got caught
yeah
but yeah good times you got caught like
your mom walked in and you're like mid i
don't i do i dress
no i don't think that's how it went down
again like
subtle memories of just like i feel like
if i peed in my room my mom or like oh
this wasn't to smell it this wasn't one
time in the room this is our living room
oh my god wait you didn't sell that part
oh yeah it was in our living room that's
a community space yeah dude
so were you kind of like i gotta make
sure nobody finds out i'm doing this
yeah but you'd sneak out there yeah i
mean i remember one time i was watching
[ __ ] uh
i think it was a phantom menace yeah
and i'm like [ __ ] i gotta pee right now
and i just [ __ ] whipped it out and
just you know bombs away you were the
how could they not notice that
i don't i was alone when i was watching
but the smell i mean my god and there's
just got to be a shitload of liquid on
the ground
yeah where did the liquid go in the
chest it just pulled at the bottom it
doesn't pull in the chest there's no way
it's water tight
it was a chest there were toys in it it
got all over the toys and i'm sure at
the bottom of the
oh my god
now i just [ __ ] on lawns yeah you
graduated now
pee in pools that's right
don't forget about that right
right right so yeah
i'll have to ask my mom more details but
yeah
you know
i thought of another one that i maybe
wanted to tell but i'm
i just
i may have told it already but i think
it was off the air the other day when
the kart knarks guy came on yeah
i think it was after the show did i tell
you go ahead let's hear it i'll tell you
the thing
what's it about
so
when i was probably like
15 or 16 you know some of my buddies
started to get cars i don't think i had
one yet but um you know again we were
definitely delinquent kids and
did all kinds of
very stupid things uh
once we had access to uh vehicles but
one thing that we used to do
fairly often i would say a number of
times
was something that we called karting
which
basically
consisted of finding abandoned shopping
carts out in a neighborhood
rolling down the windows of the car
somebody would hang out of the window
holding on to the shopping cart
and we
get going like
40 50 miles an hour down a residential
street like pushing the cart along the
side and then we would bowl them into
people's trash cans and [ __ ] oh my god
release it that sounds dangerous very
dangerous yeah very [ __ ] stupid
used to do it
quite and
i feel like we
would have been good friends we would
have gone on great cam so did anything
ever go sideways doing that uh
not that i can reca i mean sometimes it
got real crazy like it would hit it
would like impact the trash can fly up
10 feet in the air and like flip and
stuff but i can't nobody ever got hurt
thank god dude but yeah
it's crazy when i think like
so much of us have done
horrible things as kids
and like it's just a matter of chance
that we didn't like kill someone yeah
because there's like people whose lives
are just totally [ __ ] they go to like
juvenile
they like have this tremendous guilt i
mean their life is like totally [ __ ]
imagine someone like that it hit someone
and they died yeah it could have
happened really to to any of us it's
kind of just
crazy i have a story i was thinking
about but it literally makes me seem
like a crazy well that's good let's hear
it i still think about it and feel so
horrible to this day like i could have
blinded a kid is what happened splash
acid in his face or something
like you're not far off
okay i was in a sandbox at school and it
was like the grainy rocky sand and my
friend and i were like building
like
we were pretending it was a food of some
sort we were like making cakes and this
kid you know like
the booger kid of the class
the one who's like all snotty and picks
his nose and he had like cooties to us
he came up and he wanted to play and at
the end of like
the eating segment of our game it was
time for all of us to enjoy the cake and
we put our hand out like for him to mime
eat the cake and he went in and like
almost licked my hand so i threw the
like rocked up sand all in his eyes and
i remember him looking up at me with
rocks like
i couldn't even see his eyes that's how
covered they were in sand
and i lost my dam like i just started
crying he was in shock like he isn't
even crying yet you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] blinded this kid and then
you started crying yeah bro
it was kind of like
how old were you i was in like prime i
was in like
before first grade bro it's not that bad
the
teacher
are you kidding me but you just i'm just
saying you're you're propositioned like
you're some psycho kid i mean it's just
not that bad
i look back on it and i'm
i feel so horrible i've thought about
reaching out let it go man you let it go
yeah we've all had sand in our eyes
it was like it was so much sand he was
fine right
after like
a long time in the bathroom with the t
with two teachers
if you really feel that guilty maybe you
could reach out and send him a dm oh
wait you probably can't read it
because he's blind hilarious
damn ladies and gentlemen but that's the
story i didn't want to tell
that's really not that bad also you were
so young who would blame you for that
actually yeah he grew up and his name is
jeff widdick
thank you well didn't didn't david
dobrik blind with a pine cone can i
actually tell you something interesting
because we did friendship is over with
jeff mike is my new best friend right
he just dm me
jeffrey
jeff oh okay he said um
hey bro i'm off twitter
uh don't replace me with mike
he says thanks for helping me out with
everything by the way
i was just [ __ ] around on the pod so
gracious um i knew i knew that
i knew that we had something special me
and jeff
i knew it
best we're best friends forever i could
never drop you jeff
we're dogs
okay even
you think frenemies with me mike and
jeff
like a frenemy's triangle love triangle
be a good show
would it
i think so
too much testosterone but so much chaos
i feel like would be produced
[Music]
well anyway uh thank you uh jeff we're
besties again thanks bro
i take back what i said all of it
best guy best guy i know
yeah i feel like i don't know i've
thrown sand i've thrown rocks in people
i mean this is all chaos it's warfare
out there olivia
i mean yeah it's all violence if you
really think about it it's all violence
being expressed
so you're good don't worry about it
thank you thank you yeah you grew up in
southern california did you have those
trees
that dropped those little seed pods that
are like little spikes little [ __ ]
everywhere
yeah everywhere dude we didn't like we
were just there's weapons on the ground
and so we didn't have snow here so we
would just use the spike ball pull up
pull up a picture so people know what
we're talking about those [ __ ] hurt
man
i can't express they were everywhere
every grass was and sidewalk was
littered with these little bombs
do you feel like
has something changed since we were kids
because i feel like i don't see those
all the time maybe
these things
and they're super spiky and super strong
they hurt man they get attached to their
clothes
chuck these [ __ ] at each other
i have no idea what those are dude
these are weapons weapons
on the ground somebody said they're
called sycamore seed pods you know i've
seen them my entire life and i never
actually knew it yeah i think they're
still around down we're just not
drinking around school campuses for some
reason they plant those on every school
they're like let's plant the tree that
produces weapons yeah it's kind of
insane oh i pulled up the sycamore one
that
it looks kind of different but maybe
this is what they looked like before no
no talking about sweet gums
sweet gums of course has some [ __ ] up
name like that
sweet gum
that's it enough nailed it of course
they're called sweet gum
yup
and like those spikes look kind of like
weak those were very strong yeah
you could stomp it and it wouldn't break
and you [ __ ] slip on them all the
time too because they're just like these
little it's like having marbles all over
your [ __ ] playground sweet gum pods
there's nothing sweet about those things
nothing
uh who else we got ian we got sam we got
i guess that's it right
i have a story oh lena yes i'd love to
hear your story okay i just thought of
this one it's really mean i don't know
how i could have done that but um
in lebanon so the electricity cuts out
like every so often and my sister got
stuck in the elevator once and i could
hear her like pounding on the elevator
door for someone to come and help her
because you can turn on like the
generator you just tell like the
building operator he'll turn on the
generator and get the power back
and instead of helping her i just let
her
stay there because it's stained elevator
stuck because um earlier that day we had
fought she took the game boy from me so
there were six of us and we shared three
game boys and she just took it from me
and we fought for about that so when the
elevator incident happened i just
i didn't help
so how long was she trapped in the
elevator it wasn't that long it was like
15 minutes and i knew it would like come
back the
building operator would be notified
eventually so it wasn't like that big of
a deal and and was she pissed at you
when you came out oh she was so mad yeah
she like came in screaming at me and i
did i felt bad after that because i
didn't know it was like completely dark
in there and like she where she got
stuck it was like completely wall
covering her and
were you just playing game boy the whole
time
i don't remember what i was doing i was
by the door at first and i i heard her
like pounding the whole time but
did you say anything or did you just
peace out
when she saw me no when you heard her
pounding did you say anything like see a
loser oh no no i didn't go out there the
way the way her sister describes it's a
little different yeah tell me she says
that lena was looking cause it wasn't it
wasn't on the complete floor if i'm not
mistaken
i don't know she i guess lena was at an
angle and i guess they closed on her
sister and she was yelling out to her
name and lena gave her a smile you know
like a
like a and just bailed like a mufasa
scar type thing yeah you barely see me
though so how could she know that no i'm
just saying
it was like the glass was you know and
she can't see me perfectly
listen to me a smile she she gave
this one right here
yeah exactly that's exactly walked away
well if you want my opinion lina she had
it coming yeah you don't mess with the
kids game boy period yeah but the chat
seems to be saying justified yeah yeah
you're good you're good i don't feel so
bad anymore
we're solving all our problems here
today
the therapy's fully justified
it's on somebody snatching my game boy
it's on
i blame my parents they had six kids and
like two game boys
oh yeah that's a recipe for disaster
tough that's tough you know that that
yeah there's going to be fights
attempted murders but yeah
what game did you play on game boy lino
um it was one of those mario world
okay games yeah that's hardcore gaming
that's hard it is those those games were
tough mario world the early mario games
were all tough
love that game
have you beaten that lena
yeah plenty of times the whole mario
world full clear
yeah i mean there wasn't a lot to do in
lebanon especially when we go to visit
relatives my parents would sit there
like all day
damn oh i hate that dude they would do
we would do that in israel every friday
we would go to my elis family's house
and [ __ ] sit there all day dude all
day
like all day i can't emphasize that
enough
and they got mad when i didn't come so i
had to come every time
just sit there is it was it like that
lena
yeah same for us like it would be rude
if not all the kids came
they take it personal yeah yeah yeah
same
there you go i didn't know you were a
pro gamer that's great good for you
thank you yeah
check it out lina pro gamer go home
gamer girl
uh and finally well we have we have a
sam and ian right you guys have stories
to share
i was honestly such a good kid
i don't think i ever did anything like
super bad
i so believe that
i was so afraid of like see i was
getting spanked so i don't know i was
afraid i was too scared maybe it didn't
work it worked
i was wrong
um
i guess uh
off top my head the one that pops pops
up is um
my friend group sort of had like an open
door
policy i guess you know we kind of grew
up
it was very communal so you could just
go over to so-and-so's house the door
would be open
hey is everyone here and you just go in
pop in yes
pop in okay and um that was nice for a
while but then
that access sort of
allowed us to kind of [ __ ] with each
other in a way so we kind of started
messing with each other
i don't remember what started it i think
someone let off like a
like a fart bomb in someone's room oh
[ __ ] that is like one of those really
nasty ones and then it
went back and forth
at one point we went into someone's our
friend's house like dressed as ninjas
and we like took
his playstation
and we like stole it
and then we gave it to him later but
the one that pops in my head was
i don't remember what my friend did
first
but one day he wasn't home and like
seven of us went over to his house his
mom wasn't there either
and we went upstairs to his room
and we just
flipped everything upside down
like every item in his room and then
also this like hallway
and it took all of us like giant pieces
of furniture we were we flipped
everything like bed beds upside down
yeah
like yeah dresser the frame of the bed
dressers drawers so did it just look
like a bomb went off in there like a
robbery it was pretty [ __ ] up like
literally like his bed frame
every single item there
locked down we flipped it
and his mom came home
we got out we got him we got out it was
a quick operation
and his mom was so mad and she was
calling all of our parents she was
threatening to call the police
really yeah she was really she didn't
get the game because like i said there
was like seven or eight of us
and we we were flipping things for like
like
it was like 45 minutes to an hour of
flipping wait did you flip stuff outside
of his room too
i think kind of it bleeding into the
hallway a bit
[ __ ]
but um
yeah so like it would have taken a long
time
for just him and his mom to unflip it oh
[ __ ] and yeah she was really mad
we weren't allowed to
we weren't allowed to
go in there anymore she was like don't
[ __ ] come in here
so like my things unless i'm here so
so did they start locking their door
after that
i think yeah we had to like make sure
we're like hey
um we're coming over
yeah
so that's pretty awesome that's actually
that's great
yeah
um it was good times there you have it a
full flipped room
yeah my mom would have freaked the [ __ ]
out if my friends did that she would
have gone ape [ __ ]
yeah did you guys go back and help them
re unflip it no see that would have been
a good thing to do
that would have been a good thing to do
yeah
but no
that's a good story actually that's a
good one what other kind of shenanigans
you get up to an open door policy that
that's interesting
i mean
i don't know we just would [ __ ] around i
i'm trying to think of anything else
nothing's popping in my head i like the
fart bomb in your friend's room that is
vicious
did you ever like ding dong ditch or do
anything yep dude you did all that [ __ ]
yeah that was the biggest adrenaline
adrenaline the adrenaline rush as a
child i love ditching yes yeah so fun i
used to do that all the time i tp we
used to toilet paper houses all the time
yeah when cam was like i don't think we
ever tp at anybody's house but we
hit the pumpkins or whatever yeah he was
telling his story
we i've tp see i've never done the
pumpkins but i've tp'd dude and we used
to go so hard bro we would have like tp
parties where they'd sleep over
we would go buy like 200 rolls
like we would go as hard as [ __ ]
possible you could not even see
the the house wall by the time we were
done what about egging do you ever egg
houses only once my
[Music]
we followed principal
home yes we followed him home
and then we [ __ ] egged this house
yeah
he used to do that uh quite often as
well you guys ever said we were a
delinquents man i guess so i thought
this [ __ ] was normal kid stuff did you
guys have like a fire stage where you
just lit everything on fire
i knew a kid that was like that kid but
i i didn't i never had that that
pyromaniac uh streak in me yeah
necessarily but i did have a friend who
who did and and
got in some trouble for it you you went
through a pyro well it was my friend the
one who later in life i've told the
story on the show before he used to take
my socks and wipe off into them
okay when we were in college but when we
were younger yeah this guy used to light
everything on fire he used to like make
little like molotov cocktails and like
throw him at a park at like midnight
jesus no one would be there yeah he was
he was a bad egg he was always a bad egg
yeah but uh i don't know how you live
with the dude who jerks off into your
socks man i didn't know at the time i
mean sometimes you're getting
i'd say jerking off is the like lightest
thing he did into your socks i mean well
no he would he would he wouldn't give
him back he would just okay all right at
least you at least you wouldn't go wear
them yeah i would just be like where are
all my socks like you mine sucks
i used to put smoke bombs in people's
mailbox
did that sound colorful yeah you did
that colored one you could buy this from
the ice cream man right exactly right
yep that's where i got oh yeah i know
you will get fart bombs yeah they have
all kinds of [ __ ] ice cream man bro
kind of psycho that they would oh yeah
that kind of stuffed children but you
knew you knew he had it yep he always
had what else kind of [ __ ] did we get
into that was like kind of normal
did you guys prank call oh wait oh all
the time i [ __ ] favorite i [ __ ]
still prank call people oh
i'm not gonna say but same yeah yeah i
did all that [ __ ]
oh we used to get real [ __ ] up though
when we had tp people's house we would
put like rice in the grass because we
heard that [ __ ] up their grass
or we would buy like thousands of forks
and stab it in their grass oh the fork
thing i did the fork thing just for no
reason just to be a dick because the
toilet paper's too easy to clean right
you just have to be a [ __ ] dick for
no reason
chested axe body spray bomb exactly
that shit's deadly man
i don't know if i told this but there
was a thing
in middle school where people would piss
in a [ __ ] bottle and try to get you
to drink it
now that's [ __ ] up
one time
my friend went in the bathroom pissed in
a bottle of coke and gave it to this
other friend he ended up drinking it
went to the hospital went to the
principal the police came oh boy
and we had like a huge meeting with the
cops
and they took the bottle to get tested
for urine because his family wanted to
like sue them
and apparently the cop said that the
bottle spilled i think
they were like he was like let's not
ruin anyone's life over this right is
what i'm assuming but that that was a
huge trouble yeah
that was a big big trouble time
see that i think i've told this story
that happened to a kid at my school but
he came in the bottle right oh yeah i
know even i know wait he came in the
bottle and got to try to get someone to
drink it he dre the guy drank it and the
guy got expelled
oh he got expelled yeah
oh that is gross that's horrific how do
you not see the jizz in there
it was in like a snapple bottle oh my
gosh yeah that's traumatic yeah it's
[ __ ] if i oh man that's that's that's
tough it's like to the point where it's
like not even funny it's just fun
well we had the same when my friend was
pissing in the bottle we were all kind
of like this is like it's probably too
far pretty gnarly dude but no one
stopped him we just kind of watched it
happen
[Music]
i have a couple of small ones that i'm
curious if you guys did
okay uh
so
we had these tests that we called like
tests and the manly test and the alpha
test what was the name of the first one
you said i said
because we called it
everyone called it very bad stuff and
then just a test
he was self-censoring i think
self-censoring yeah oh bleep bleep test
yeah weep test what do you actually call
it
some manly tests let's say that and
we for example one of them were
uh you take like one of these school
erasers that you do that you just remove
uh pens with and you rub it on your skin
or
for like five minutes or something till
it starts to bleed and if you did that
you're a man
and we also had this thing where we
put your knuckle on like a table
and then your friend like
sends uh nickels dude we did this oh
yeah
yeah yeah i remember a very common game
yep yep called knuckles i think yep
i always thought people were insane for
playing that i wasn't into it
or just bloody knuckles where you would
just straight up
i think that's why my hands still shake
to the stage
yeah i had friends that played bloody
knuckles until they honestly started
bleeding oh yeah no and i was like
not for me not for me
and uh the the thing that uh brought it
up to my in my head was the the axe
spray
you you'd ah this is [ __ ] disgusting
i can't believe we did this but you
would spray it on your nipple
uh till it [ __ ] froze people did that
wait absolutely
yeah
it was a compressed air or something
that it was like a thing on the because
it becomes super cold when you spray it
on one spot for more than like two
seconds you would freeze your nips
yep
fun people i didn't personally do the uh
nip freezing but uh definitely occurred
in my friend group
that's a lot yeah
and
you know might know what my dad told me
they used to do
and this just goes to show that
people and life is becoming less [ __ ]
up okay
my dad said to to get high they used to
choke each other unconscious
yeah we did that too
there's this there's this
where you sit like a shirt you make a
share of your body so
i
you put your knees out
against against the like a wall do you
guys understand what i mean so you sit
with your legs out like that and your
your uh chest straight up i guess oh
yeah
and if you do that long enough and hold
your breath you pass out and get like a
small seizure
what the hell i don't know what you're
talking about wow i haven't thought of
that in forever kids
kids are wild
you guys ever have like bullies twist
your nipples and be like name five
cereals yes i've had a titty twister
about it it happened to me once i
started freaking out and i started
naming like doritos and cheetos and he's
like no i said cereal i'm like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
uh and one last thing
my just to follow what you said before
ethan about watching your dad's
collection
my friend once came to school and this
was probably when we were eight or nine
years old and he says i have this video
you guys got to watch it after school so
we all went home to him
and
it was
three guys one hammer oh no me and my
friends oh jesus at eight years old wait
what is three guys one hammer i just
told cam about that was the first
youtube video i ever watched i just told
them that story this morning wait i
don't know what three guys oh my god it
traumatized me
what is it just describe it to me it's a
here love do you want to do it
uh i mean yeah it's basically just
[Music]
two dudes uh in russia that found that
like just found weak people and they
pulled them out into the woods and they
mutilated them with a hammer was it
really recorded it was like supposed uh
holy enough film [ __ ]
oh it's real because they're in jail for
it and they killed 40 people yeah jesus
whoa
oh here it is
ukrainian serial killers responsible for
a string of murders
whoa and people kids were watching yeah
they're called the dinero petrov maniacs
that's pretty and they did it to dogs
and all that [ __ ] and
that [ __ ] me up i think like
permanently yeah there was 12 people
that did that
no they did it to 40 people two dudes
and the reason they could do it for so
often was because they meticulously
picked their victims to be like weak
people so they could never
[ __ ] that up
and they kept them alive for as long as
possible well none of us did anything as
bad as that so oh my god that's horrible
yeah we watched all the [ __ ] that's
so sad
and uh yeah i mean yeah i used to wat i
when i was okay we'd go to rotten.com
and i was always i had a very hard time
watching that kind of gore
even as a kid but that's really sad that
you saw that that's just [ __ ] and
horrific man yeah a lot there's a lot of
people in chat saying that i saw that it
[ __ ] me up too yeah
it makes
makes you like really
dissociate with like brutal stuff so i
have a hard time
caring about things i think only because
of because i saw that at that very young
age
but to be honest back back back in the
day during medieval times people used to
watch people get hung so like on a daily
basis
but that sounds more [ __ ] vile
i was not on 4chan someone said i never
went to 4chan
i went there one time as a teenager
because i was curious and i saw cp
straight up jesus on my first visit and
i said peace out i'm not coming back
here and that was on the main forum
like like on b b yeah or what b is where
all that [ __ ] was or random i don't know
what's over the b was random yeah so it
was like people would post it and then
it would get removed from but like but a
bunch of people saw it and i was like
what the [ __ ] and i just i haven't been
back since i went there one time and it
was so [ __ ] up and i never came back
isn't that crazy
yep
well in a good way i don't think that
kind of gory stuff is as easy to find on
the internet today
as it was i don't think
yeah maybe you might be right i don't
know i mean it's certainly still
findable but
i mean
i mean everybody just knew about
rotten.com and it wasn't it wasn't
really like hidden it was just like
there was just this website with a bunch
of videos that [ __ ] is way worse than
porn like watching people get murdered
and stuff oh yeah that was really [ __ ]
up 100
the thing is now google sensors all that
[ __ ] before you could just google it and
you can find it instantly right yeah i
don't
know it's hard people say like leak has
everything yeah look
no lively doesn't they post [ __ ] up
[ __ ] but not like not like super [ __ ]
up [ __ ] i think
but i guess you can find it if you
really look for it but as a kid you know
it's not as easy to find
yeah we were definitely
yeah i think you're right actually
because now that i'm thinking about it
it's like
nowadays
people don't just like [ __ ] randomly
like click bait each other with like
goatsy and stuff yeah yeah like that was
like really common that was
goat do you guys remember goats he was a
dude spreading open his [ __ ] like
insanely wide yeah i mean i remember he
had a he has a wedding ring on
and uh you would like send a message and
you were like
it was like it was like rick rolling but
with a way more vile thing than a stupid
music video and which is crazy because
again i was like eight the first time i
saw goats you probably do you guys
remember one guy one jar
i remember that name i don't know maybe
that video remember
you guys reminded me of this thing that
was supposed to be like a tracker and
you would always tell people you know in
school like kids would be like this
thing will track you right here right
now put it in and it'll be like a map
like a google map and it'll keep zooming
in zooming in and then it should be a
big dick on screen like spinning
and every kid got caught with that
yeah one of the other big ones was like
lemon party
old people yeah two old dudes like
blowing each other or something i don't
know there was a lemon party virus that
we used to send it to each other
but that shouldn't like smoke that
shit's like funny and like shocking but
yeah the murder [ __ ] is really
the
that [ __ ] like you can't unsee
yeah pain olympics i saw that one really
[ __ ] me up but i never knew if it was
apparently the pain olympics is
confirmed fake i don't know
you guys remember meat spin you just go
to the website is a dude just spitting
his dick right like a helicopter
did you guys ever get on i think it was
called like run the gauntlet
run the there was like a cringe edition
too but it's like there's 25 videos and
they get like progressively more [ __ ]
up oh you see like how far you can get
right now that's where i saw the hammer
video and like the ass jar like a
serious game
it's so [ __ ] up i wonder what's the
last stage of that the hammer
wait i think there's it's yeah i think
it's the hammer video but there was one
i remember there was like a
like trigger warning but like a
beheading and it's [ __ ] up it's like
really [ __ ] up
oh god lovely yeah that we were there
when the internet was
crazy [ __ ] crazy dude
yeah faces of death man that was a video
that you could rent they had like
commercials for it in the middle of the
night
there's one thing to consider nowadays
though
the weirdest most like brutal [ __ ] can
come up on your tick tock feed when you
at least uh expect it i don't know if
you guys ever see that that's happened
to me
yeah i have seen the worst i've seen on
my tick tock feed is like i i used to
get a lot of animal abuse which was so
infuriating because i would report it
every time and they would just show more
to me but i haven't seen any but i mean
that's obviously you must like this yeah
exactly i'm reporting it every time they
took that as a signal that i love it
but um what did you see that was so
[ __ ] up on um
i i think the worst thing
uh like some burned dude like he that
literally just got burned he had like
four third degree burns and he was just
running around as trying to get help
like really crazy
and i report it and then like two days
later you get you get like a
notification we found nothing wrong with
this video
it's like still all good
yeah
i've got the most [ __ ] up [ __ ] i've
seen on tick tock is like weird porn
stuff that like
and then it stays up forever like they
just somehow missed it dude like when a
dude's [ __ ] is out like obviously or i
see one funny thing that shows up from
on my page time to time is
[ __ ] breastfeeding videos which is
obviously done with the sexual intent
with kids breastfeeding and that [ __ ] is
so gnarly dude i've seen people [ __ ]
on tick tock live
really it'll be scrolling just be
[ __ ] i'm like what
opened my eyes to this tick tock life is
[ __ ] up it's really i've never spent
time on that oh yeah it's so bizarre
yeah
i love tic-tac-toe it's you see you see
for
that obviously the [ __ ]
it's crazy yeah there there's i've seen
straight [ __ ] multiple times
really yeah wait are you talking about
the one where the girl was like
pretending that she's having sex and
she's like
no i've actually i remember those tell
me that i've seen straight up
penetration
really yeah there was a genre
that was really popular i know what
you're talking about where the girl
would just sit there like yes i used to
get those all the time they have like a
million viewers yeah yeah yeah
ethan
your homework for tonight is just go
home and scroll through tick tock live
i'll check it out
it's
it's a whole other world
i'm curious have you guys seen like
there's this one older dude in the
middle and there's like a couple kids
around and they're every time they get a
donation they scream thank you thank you
thank you and i they sit there all day i
saved one of those streams once and i
came back like four hours later and
they're still sitting there like five
kids thank you thank you thank you
yeah they're probably doing bank
wherever they live
yeah probably the richest kid in that
village shot labor to the maximum super
size oh maybe yeah maybe they're just
six yeah that probably makes more sense
that's a crazy business i bet that's
like a boom that's like a pretty
lucrative business just get a bunch of
kids
to say thank you every time a donation
what a weird world bro
yeah love put on your um child filter
and try it out sometime your your baby
oh yeah yeah i should
[ __ ]
well there you have it i gotta pee
really bad and it's almost five so eel
is going to kill me if i
stay up any longer
let's get out of here
thanks for watching everybody it was a
fun episode we covered a lot of ground
indeed so we'll be back
oh one of these days you're going to go
you're going to pull
every time he plays it i'm like tense
you're going to pull the real one
maybe maybe not doubtful
i feel it coming get it started
but uh it was fun on wednesday do we
have any guests or anything uh happening
this week um
uh no guess uh we do
have i'll tell you off the air but we
have something
real good planned for wednesday really
yep
fun
so tune in for that you
people are
people are gonna like what they see
so yeah we'll see you guys on wednesday
and uh be good have a good week until
then and and stay blessed as they say
and uh you know
family family everything
all right guys
see you good night
[Music]
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family valley family
family family family family family